[Music]
so
open to anyone
all around the world
the chess.com global championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars no that is not a
typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous
we began with thousands of players
now only dozens remain
there it is oh my god
this is crazy eric hanson moves on to
the round of 32 in armageddon fashion
the cgc knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very
very real
[Music]
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends
it's the cgc round of 64.
who will take the next step to toronto
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
chess.com global championship knockout
round of 64. today is our second day of
exciting chess yesterday we capped off
uh a bracket killer of a day uh
obviously
uh with eric hanson defeating uh the
quang liam toward the end of our show
i'm levi rosman that's robert hess and
robert uh how was uh how was that day
one of games for you
honestly you couldn't have scripted any
more exciting we started off with an
armageddon match between nihal saarin
and ralph mohamed of and nihal showed us
his bullet prowess winning with just a
few seconds on his clock and then of
course in the later session we had two
matches go to armageddon the chess bra
makes it through to the next round as
did uh many other strong competitors
that's what happens in this field nobody
is weak so levy day two promises to be
just as exciting yeah this was the group
i was the most excited about when they
offered a broadcast slot i said yeah i
gotta get into this one where four of
the eight players are world champions
and one of them was nearly a world
champion you can't script up this group
any better we have to get through a few
of the logistics of the event so let's
go take a look at that first just a
reminder of the format it's single
elimination knockout this is everybody's
favorite type of chess format uh well i
i'll say it's my favorite type of chess
format i think robert i speak for you as
well
time control is 15 minutes with two
seconds bonus uh and it is a four game
match so if you win two and a half out
of the four then you move on in the
knockouts but if you don't there is an
armageddon now this is new right i don't
know if this has been implemented i'm
sure it's been implemented somewhere in
some event but the players actually bid
four minutes on the clock to get the
draw odds with the black pieces in the
armageddon uh robert how many minutes
did nihal start with yesterday with
black
you start with 11 minutes that's been
the popular bid thus far is around the
11 12 minute mark but without increment
levy and your opponent getting 15
minutes in the white pieces that's
proven quite scary but as we saw
yesterday with nihal sauron eric hansen
jose martinez they all made it through
in armageddon so it's a whirlwind of a
format but it's been really really a fun
thing to behold yeah it's going to be
tough to to beat guys who are 3 000
rated in bullet in time scrambles uh of
course yes being down four minutes is
substantial but that that is the format
it's a very interesting bidding format
for the armageddon um of course our
field 64 players there's eight groups
you do the math 32 were invited because
when you've made a successful chess
career you
oftentimes do get invitations and seated
into things but we also had a brutal
qualification stage i mean honestly it
was like the hunger games uh and and 32
people qualified their way in to now try
to beat those that receive the
invitations to the events uh we have
hikaru duda you know you see them there
wesley so fabiano nepo i can't believe
nepo's fifth on that list but i guess
they did it uh based on the groups
i i feel like i feel like nipple should
have been second but i guess nepo is in
group e so it makes a little bit of
sense um you see it right there folks i
mean so many different types of world
champions in fact the most that group is
the one in front of you today that's
group f let's take a look
i did the bracket preview for this one
i was so pumped i mean i was just
honestly so excited for this group uh
robert any thoughts
any thoughts i have too many thoughts i
unless it hit me
well you look at this group from top to
bottom and when the number eight seed in
the group is juwon jun who is capable of
knocking out aneesh giri you know it's
going to be a fun time and well look at
these two matchups in the middle here
veslyn topalov fide world champion
raunak sedwani who was born the year
that topolov was world champion and you
have the world rapid champion abdusatar
as you mentioned boris gelfand almost
knocked out
vichy anand who's also in this group in
over-the-board classical play for the
world champion title so all of these
names have a shot and don't count out he
may be the least known player in the
group but pavel poncratov he's made a
name for himself in the online sphere
he's been a great grandmaster for a long
while now so let me from top to bottom
there's not a single name that you can
say has no chance here yeah it's just an
unbelievable group i i'll say it once
i'll say it again i
it whether you give the edge to
norderbeck who is literally the reigning
defending champion of the world in the
rapid format uh of course they don't
play 15 plus two
whenever they they have the world rapid
and blitz but it doesn't really matter
he is obviously been crowned as the best
player in the world at this specific
type of chess but you also have guys who
have been the overall champions of of
chess in the world
literally every matchup here has a story
so okay get it off the screen or else
we're going to talk about it for the
entire
entire show we got to tell you about the
prizes just for qualifying you make you
make a nice little five thousand dollar
prize fund making it to the round of 32
is 10 and then obviously it goes higher
and higher depending on how you finish
but a million bucks and prizes so
very exciting
robert and i used to battle for 100
bucks first place at marshall chess club
i think roberts won uh you won a few
opens i feel like you won a few opens
and uh i think just for making it to the
round of 64 in this event robert you you
would even get more than that so
you certainly do the prize fund is very
high here it's a lot of excitement for
sure based on vying for the title and
the money but
we have these five match-ups today levy
you said get it off screen of course
they bring it back because we also are
adding maxime vacher legrav
if you didn't have enough from the group
f
we get dessert with maxim and eduardo
and okay you don't need to say more than
three letters when you're talking about
maxine by sherlock ralph yeah you
literally don't uh mvl
is uh is an acronym just etched in
history and that that forever will be
the frenchman uh with is is it three
names i think it's egos by three names
or is it two names but
frenchmen with three names uh that
matchup from group h will also be added
today that's more of a schedule thing
scheduling thing i think one of them
just i think they had to play today but
uh yeah you have five exciting matchups
in today's round and um
the bracket contest so
we're super excited we had 10 000
bracket submissions if you've never
filled out a bracket that's as simple as
it sounds you pick people who are going
to win in every match-up and we were
going to give the person that won a
perfect bracket 100 000. ninety-nine
percent of people lost after yesterday
because eric hansen decided to show up
and fulfill my prediction
let it be known
and beat liquin liam so now i think we
only have like three or four hundred
people uh and uh the who have the
opportunity to win a hundred thousand
dollars uh before our games today we
have a uh a super cool preview video uh
shout out to the production team who's
made a few of these for the players
let's go watch one for ronix edwani
impressively one of five junior players
from his country rated over 2600
at age 13 raunak sidwani became just the
ninth youngest grand master in history
sedwani has momentum coming off a
memorable performance this summer at the
44th olympiad in which his team of
outstanding youngsters were able to
defeat the top seeded united states and
ultimately grab the bronze medal
competing in play in number nine of the
cgc in late july sidwani foreshadowed
his success to come in the olympiad
notching eight of the nine available
points
oh my gosh what a play
from around
one he's really putting on a show right
now
ironically enough to secure his spot in
the round of 64 zedwani still had to get
through another teenage sensation from
india pranav v
unfazed zedwani sealed the deal
heroic defense from san juan gives him
the second win in a row in this playoff
and he's off to the knockout stages
in the main bracket the 16 year old star
finds himself in a challenging
experienced group including fellow
countryman and legend vishwanathan anand
in another twist zaduani's first round
opponent was the feed-a-champion the
same year sedwani was born
sedwani will need to tap into more magic
from his fruitful summer to make travel
plans to toronto
playing against top grand masters it's
like awesome and hopefully i can keep
going further in the knockouts as well
yeah robert uh what more to say uh
raunak is among a group of
talented juniors in india who are just
soft-spoken killers like
uh
26 2700 elo
in classical and just able to translate
that so effortlessly the faster and
faster the format goes
but this is a nerve-wracking event like
we saw yesterday jose uh
i'm thinking of jose mourinho but uh uh
jose martinez uh
yesterday i was seeing i've never seen
the guy so stressed before yesterday
like i i i thought he was just like
super chill guy playing his blitz
playing his rapid but he was stressed a
lot of people are stressed you see
people breathing eating their shirts a
million bucks is on the line not for the
winner it's two hundred thousand but
overall i think that uh that that brings
that brings that out in the players and
ronaldo is a really nice kid like i got
to hang out with him at the olympia we
played some table tennis we've got some
board games and yeah you're right this
is a huge moment in his career he won a
medal with the india two team at the
olympiad now he has a chance to beat a
former world champion in a four game
match that is a big accomplishment if
he's able to achieve it and what's so
exciting about this tournament levy is
we have the teenager versus the legend
so who's the favorite there where vessel
is obviously the higher rated player and
historic player but raonic may become a
historic player in his own right so it's
going to be really exciting in that 4-5
matchup
yeah for example boris gelfand who is in
this group actually trains the indian
team i don't know if he does that as a
full-time job if that was a part-time
gig and
tobolov was coaching in the u.s like
they're at the stage of their career
where it's time to bust out the
knowledge upon the younger generation
unfortunately they also at times have to
play them in brutal rapid knockouts so
you give them all the tools to win and
then they're going to use it against you
because they're savages uh and i i think
we're off i think i think clocks are
running and uh topolof begins with d4
oh here we go so we'll see what veronica
has in store for uh vessel and that when
you play somebody like vessel topolov
you don't know which version of him
you're going to get we saw kramnik be
absolutely dominant yesterday so moral
degradation aside i mean vladimir is
here and he's here to stay but for
topalov he's struggled in over-the-board
events in recent years when he does come
out of his i don't call it retirement
but he has a an extended vacation in
terms of his chest career
so uh right away right we don't see g5
from uh from ronic he doesn't go for the
aggressive kind of knight e4 g5 kind of
stuff it's a very solid opening thus far
uh from the from the players it seems
yeah it's as you were pointing out g5 is
an approach that is acceptable in many
of these rogozin also the nimzo you see
it a plate the king would look weak but
white doesn't have firepower but whoa
that is a an offering here levy queen on
d8 hanging but so is the queen on c3
yup
yes sir uh that's uh that's not a queen
hang don't worry we're not gonna have a
highlight just yet
but
yeah that's that's
what what choice does white have i mean
can white just go back like maybe queen
b3 or something
yeah i guess you can go queen b3 but
then i'm even more tempted to play g5
and well vessel choose queen a3 not a
square you see every day for that queen
uh levy what do you think g5 happening
or i mean knight g5 seems tempting wow
night chief i would never i would i
would never by the way sick arrows can i
just say i mean this might be the
highlight of the tournament right here
we got we got three different colors on
the board all right knight df6 of course
yeah g5 and h5 looked really interesting
uh but uh i i guess it's game one you
know what i mean i guess it's a feeler
game if it's game three and
it's you know you're up one and a half
half you're getting confident then okay
you know maybe you're gonna play uh
you're gonna go for this g5 stuff but
yeah i think ronic is just gonna go for
this traditional structure
uh well speaking of traditional
structure is it c6 is that is that what
black is looking for
we'll get a little carlsbad type
structure but yeah it is odd with the
queen on a3 because normally you play b4
b5 that's a lot harder to orchestrate
with your queen in the apons path so c6
looks great to me and levia i guess i
kind of want to talk about that
psychology you were touching upon
because players with the black pieces if
you're around said wani you're happy to
make a draw in game one but don't you
think it often prevents people when
you're in a position like this when it's
just a position it's neutral it's
sometimes i think prevents them from
playing the best move because if g5 is
in fact the best choice then you should
go for it and not worry about the result
just yet yeah i agree
but that's also i'm definitely biased by
the fact that it's my playing style to
think of g5h5 and i'm generally quite
bad at evaluating whether or not i'm
getting myself into a good adventure or
a bad adventure and i feel like when the
stakes are this high and it's still the
first game and you still kind of it's a
feel-out round i think this fighters do
this as well a lot of fighters will lose
the first round just to kind of download
data and then they go on to win the next
few rounds and i i don't know if roundup
sudwani is ever going to get into an
octagon with gloves on and fight
shirtless but i think in this case you
just sort of put your pieces on squares
and you see
how the game goes but i do agree with
you the problem is
like if if all things are equal white
will apply pressure on the queen side
and black is only going to get so many
of these moves like rookie 8 and knight
f6 right so you're going to run out of
improving moves and at some point you're
going to have to do something
that's true and he plays one of those
improving moves as you were highlighting
rookie 8 rook c1 natural choice although
often times this f1 rook comes to c1
because if the plan and we see c6 is
like b4 and b5 it's probably good to
have both rooks towards the queen side
so uh topolov been doing a very natural
thing here with work a to c1 but you
know we said black only has so many
improving moves what about white like
what is topolo's plan if not this b-pawn
push
well i i really liked the idea of trying
to play
b4 b5 yeah and i was gonna also say okay
well there is g5 okay so finally it
arrives um
but see now if you take the bishop isn't
there some f takes g3 like very
counter-intuitive moves to open up the
rook it seems intuitive but what i'm
saying is that you're taught to take
toward the center but now that you
weakened your knight on f6 and your
bishop on f5 is unguarded taking this is
a lot harder and i don't know if the
move h5 here is all that good for black
like i
that's a very dangerous looking move for
both sides
yeah if you're playing for a win if
you're running sidney like you're saying
if it's game three maybe you play h5 and
say i'm holding nothing back but it just
might be the best move so you don't want
to get caught up into how risky it is
that's why ronnie has spent some time
here on the set but i like what you're
saying levy that f takes g3 coaches
you're you're the chess coach of the
internet you say you teach everybody
right that you know h takes g3 we
capture towards the center keep our
pawns and chains but f takes g3 makes a
lot of sense opening up this rook and if
it could pan out that would be very
dangerous for the king on jaden levy i
don't think either of us need to think
very hard and long about how many
instructive wins topolo has had against
an open kingside
yeah one of the one of the best kind of
like downhill you know rolling attacking
players there there there ever was and
it's interesting to see him kind of dial
it back and go for a carlsbad you know
he's uh and then just kind of play like
a queenless middle game here of course
yeah and and there is before
i wonder why the computer absolutely
hates that move
that was surprising because it looks
the obvious plan but b4 was detested by
the engine it went from slightly better
for white to almost minus one for black
so
what is it is it h5 i mean is that's the
only thing i can possibly think of
that looks pretty strong when you have
to worry about your king safety h5 h4
might just trap a piece right because
now the queens are off so black doesn't
really need to worry about
counter-attacking we're not taking the
bishop on g3 we are actually trying to
trap the bishop but h5 what i mean can
white play like h4 and then still have
this kind of f-file stuff going on
yeah it's a good point because two
pieces are hanging in a row there that
could be costly for black
see this is where ludwig chess would be
amazing because with black you have 11
minutes to figure out why it's minus one
ludwig chess of course being the format
where you see the eval bar you don't see
stockfish and see ronic doesn't doesn't
see it i also didn't see it did you have
any idea what the move was no in fact
i'm gonna go back and i'm gonna look and
i'm gonna say
okay well
apparently it's minus about one if you
play the move knight to e8
you saw that right levy i mean obviously
i guess it's to get it's to get the
carlsbad knight right like to put the
knight on d6 and then play f6 kicking
out white's knight is that the point
because i i yeah i mean that's
dank as the kids say that is just
ridiculous right like even this is one
of those moves where even if you show it
to any of these top gm's afterwards
they're like yeah okay i'm not mad at
myself for missing a minus one move with
98 it just it doesn't look like a minus
one move and knight d7 is a good move
you see it's still equal um the position
was slightly better for white then it
says slide better for black so knight d7
just trading off white's most imposing
piece i don't think that you can false
romnek for making this choice yeah
excuse me i
i also think this has a little bit to do
with psychology i could be wrong but
it's kind of one of these situations
where like it's like we've been saying
it's the first game and you're more
thinking like i'm just going to get this
knight i'm going to get rid of this
knight on e5 so i'm going to get rid of
it with my maybe my worst piece which is
that knight on f6 but what he didn't
realize is actually you can play 98 96
and get rid of it with the pawn and
actually not trade it off but rather
like kick it out completely and take
over the initiative now
yeah i mean tabal is going to play a4 i
don't think there's a whole lot here but
if rauna kind of overthinks this
position
and then
doesn't find the best defense because he
thinks his position is unpleasant
paul's going to win it's just going to
be he's just going to move forward and
convert a better end game
yeah well you said end game that made my
mind want to go elsewhere just because
the vish vishvanathan anand is playing
celeb if you don't mind can we uh hop on
over there you think and
check it out
of course
oh my favorite opening of course is on
the board here pancrata playing the
french knowing that i'm commentating
today and vishy with the white pieces
establishes his queen on f4 towards the
black king so what's your initial take
of this position the eval only says plus
0.4 but i mean obviously there's much
more to it well engineer
the the engine hates the french uh so we
have to it's a little bit biased right
it's like when you when you get selected
uh for jury duty and you have to kind of
disclose information about yourself you
can't uh be on the jury of a car
accident trial if you were once involved
in one for example well the the french
is kind of the jury duty uh you have to
disclose that the engine hates it and it
will always give advantage however what
my co-host will not tell you is that he
once drew vishwanathan anand in a
classical chess game by playing the
french did he play this against you was
it uh if we can kind of look through the
uh the the opening
what did he play i played differently
than uh punkarattub did but um yeah this
is the start of the game but i did not
play c5 at this moment so just mainline
winner stuff here and just for everybody
watching i'm sure you know you've
created so many videos levy that you've
gone over the french but in general
right this compromise pawn structure for
white is offset by the fact that there's
all of these dark square problems that
black permanently has and there's often
pressure on the king side so rook a2 is
a very funny looking move levy you don't
often play this pretty much in
i guess the black side of some slavs but
other than that you don't see a move
like rook a2 or rook a7 in the opening
yeah the french is a fascinating opening
that kind of doesn't make any sense like
black gives up a bishop to yes slightly
inconvenienced white's pawn structure
and there's many ways that black can
handle that middle game it's an opening
that i don't touch with either color
because well frankly i'm lazy and a bit
uh and and a bit of a degenerate so i
would never learn 20 moves of theory for
either side here i always try to
simplify things when it comes to the
french with either side
but black basically has this queen on a4
totally restricting white's play white
is like i don't care about that i'm
going to build up on the king side that
and as we see vichy's doing that now now
he's gonna try to kick this night out
with a pawn push a little bit later but
the truth is robert like in your
experience if you don't break through
here on the queen side with black aren't
you just dead like because white is just
gonna pressure pressure pressure and
improve and where's black's play on the
queen side where like where is it
it i don't see it it's a great question
i've never been fond of the french yes i
did uh use it against vichy but that's
because i thought it was the opening he
could least expect coming from me and
well it did work out in that one game
but as we see in this position this is
what happens in the french you have this
beautiful connect four but this is not
that board game and g4 is played it's
just free roll on the king side for
white black lack space go ahead
whoa you can get away with this i just
assume your night gets trapped yeah so i
guess pancratev is
gonna go back to f5
is he gonna sack the what
queen g5 is just trapping at night no
that that's what i'm thinking so the one
thing you don't want to do is move your
queen
on g5 what do you think is there is
there like queen b5 or queen b6 and
queen b1 at the end
oh my goodness this rook on a2 he's got
some problems we'll show that here we
have the announcement but it's a queen
g5 levy's point that if you go ahead and
take this knight then there's queen to
b1 and the rook is trapped over here
that actually is a terrible rook
you know i gotta tell you robert uh we
what the audience doesn't know is
obviously we've made some technical
adjustments to our commentary and before
we would just follow the game in life
chess i got a really bad habit of just
watching the game and if i ever wanted
to kind of see what the engine was
thinking i would turn it on i got hands
off all right i got no hands here i'm
just i'm trying to use my brain and i
think waking up at six in the morning
and drinking a nice tea i think it i
think it set my brain right i kind of
get why eric rosen uh does it having
said that
i still don't really believe in this
position like
uh i i think there's got to be something
right it's just
it looks so passive but this queen b6
move is really annoying and it's
hard to deal with i i think it's one of
these great illustrations of how you
don't have to rush certain decisions so
if the queen g5 queen b6 maybe just rook
a1 where my rook is now safe and you'll
play queen b2 to go after all these
pawns as is typical the french and i
play rook c1 and guess what my bishop is
defending this rook your knight is still
trapped and you may end up getting even
three pawns for the piece but as we can
see based on the evaluation of the
position it's not fully justified it's
interesting and there's some practical
compensation but white remains better
because you're winning a piece and you
still will harass black on the king side
yeah that we now were i think when
karate is actually like a renowned
french french expert unless i'm
completely making that up uh by the way
did
wait did knight f5 happen yeah he just
went back oh so he didn't even go for
this queen b6 i mean i he could have but
i but i guess yeah i guess just the
consolidation approach of rook a1 rook
c1 so he he was fully intending on the
knight to die and just making some sort
of blockade in the position which okay
that's fine wow
what
vichy's like nah i'm gonna win your
night and we're not going to trade rooks
like i'm not i mean night age this is
what i mean the french is an opening
where especially these mainline win
hours like i don't think this was quite
a cutting edge main line it was a little
bit of a sideline but
i this is the reason we don't see this
opening in classical tournaments at
super gm level anymore it's because i
feel like
black just kind of gets danced on i mean
there's just
it's it's so tough it's so so tough we
will see the classical french with
knight f6 but the winner with bishop
before i think is a rare sight it's just
a bit too much of a gamble when there's
much more solid alternatives out there
people hate the berlin but in the berlin
you don't get positions like this you
know
i was listening to you levy and i was
taking over the end but i'm still just
so mesmerized by the move knight age
seven it's so disrespectful i mean he
could have just taken his knight and
vishi's like but she has a sense of
humor he's just like no i'm not taking
it but you know it does make a lot of
sense because this rook on h1 it is
defending the white king it also is
covering that b1 square in case of a
queen b6 so the 995 immobilized because
the 97 is loose so i actually love the
decision i never would have found that
myself on being completely transparent
but if we had traded rooks on h8 instead
you can already see the evaluation is
going in black's favorite says equal but
with rook h2 check problems with this
white king over here i can completely
understand the move as it's justified i
just wouldn't have seen it in advance
yes remember this whole monologue that i
went on about waking up early and
drinking and getting like caffeinated
well i i'm i'm not can i confess
something to you robert yeah i thought
the rook on h1 was protected like
like
i mean this this is why i maybe i should
be in the second shift this entire time
i was like night at five i take the
knight i didn't it didn't even occur to
me that like i would need to trade the
rooks first and allow the control of the
h5 i'm very sorry all right like so uh
i'm with the audience on this one robert
you're you're the only adult in the room
i think you'll have to uh you'll have to
kind of take take uh take this game to
its conclusion but that that knight is a
goner it can't move because the knight
on e7 is hanging that much i definitely
will tell you yes the problem with these
superfluous knights is they're defending
each other but there's nothing else
going on so we'll come back to this game
we'll go back to the topology games to
see if anything has happened here we
also have the mbo game so maybe actually
let's go to mbl versus ituri zaga
because uh itarazaga he's spending quite
a deal of time here and i see a knight
on f5 i see a pawn on g5 and h5 so i
immediately love nbl's position
actually yeah at first glance i thought
mvl was playing with the black pieces i
thought it was some sicilian this looks
like a night or potentially was it a
night or
or which which sicilian was it and i
just thought oh mvl but then i very
quickly realized that white is up seven
minutes and i immediately knew that mvl
was playing with the white pieces so um
he's so fast he is a nightmare opponent
and
mvl plays like he has an appointment
okay like at all times
winning losing
it's such a good way of putting it levy
i've never heard that before but that is
a hundred percent accurate
yeah he just he he wants to you know
just wants to get out of there like it
it doesn't matter he plays very
instinctive chess and
uh
i feel as though
it's extremely annoying when you're
winning and he's playing fast because
you know you're winning but you need to
take a little bit of time you hesitate
and he immediately kind of capitalizes
this position though he is uh not going
to need any defense one of his pawns is
going to go forward the question is
which one f6 right at some point because
you don't want to get hit with knight f4
but
f6 is definitely the move that i was
considering because if you play h6 so i
think this is difficult because all
three pawn pushes look at minimum
reasonable and actually look quite good
so h6 would be a normal way to go for an
attack but if you make the move h6 i was
concerned that after g6 i wouldn't
actually have a weight in and that's the
big difference is this rook on h1 is
blockaded by its own pawn whereas if you
play f6 and black tries to avoid the
opening of the king with g6 well of
course now we're very happy with the
rook gaining an open file and the game's
just over as you see
out of curiosity after h6 g6 and then
the f pawns trade is black just better
i just i i'm very curious like fgfg is
black uh is black just better or is it
just equal okay it's just equal but i i
mean prospect wise this looks horrible
for white like
i i wouldn't as you were saying i
wouldn't look at the engine and be like
this eagle i immediately prefer black
i'm totally with you because end games
are all horrible for white with these
extended pawn structures so uh yeah this
is not at all what you want in mbl he is
a very aggressive player trying to make
those appointments and f6 oh he just
booked one for a checkmate attack
yep
uh f6 knight f4 i wonder if there's
bishop takes h7 but you can probably
just go queenie for
i also that's the thing when it's not my
game i'm immediately going bishop takes
h7 check right maxim should do that it's
fun if it doesn't work still robert
robert robert all right bishop h7
yeah it's not gonna happen but bishop h7
okay takes takes it's bad it's bad but i
really wanted g6 yeah king g8 it's not
going to happen h6
[Laughter]
92 hg
that's awesome
that is awesome you don't get to see
this
it it's losing basically every move and
doesn't work at all but if you got here
it would be sick oh yeah
oh yeah you just and you know you can
take the pawn g6 but rook h8 you get a
new queen on f8 uh no it doesn't work
for for many different reasons because
while it looks very imposing uh once
black eliminates instead of taking the
queen starts taking some of your pawns
you're no longer gonna have a
checkmating attack and yeah uh you're
just running out of firepower so that's
actually really funny uh variation but
knight f4 was the choice of uh itary
zaga here bishop takes h7 tempting but
that's why maxime is doing the right
thing it's instructive take your time
you're up so much time and look at this
a comm move he doesn't even play queen
e4 that move looked really strong to my
eyes but he says ah simple move queen f3
because the threat of f takes g7 is very
powerful if you play g6 i'm very happy
to open the
h file and maybe with the queen on e4
levy he was worried about getting hit
with the d5 at some point so he feels
like he's saving himself a tempo
yeah and
i i think uh
yeah there's there's definitely
i mean multiple options here for for mvl
to convert this i wouldn't be shocked if
we came back uh and he had secured this
first game
uh we have another game i think the only
game that we haven't looked at just yet
which is the world champion uh not your
back abductor
in the rapid format also olympic gold
medalist and he's got a game against
boris gelfant this one's super
interesting
uh i thought that read 17 minutes for
black but that says 12. i was like wow
gelfin really busting out some prep
robert what
opening is this i by looking at the
position i couldn't fully tell you
obviously i started some kind of d4 uh
but let's go back in time and just
quickly go through the moves here
we're not going to teach novelties and
theoretical session but bishop b2 so
this is becoming very popular uh just a
calm move to defend the knight in c3 so
you don't have to ruin your pawn
structure if it's captured but levy
these kind of positions
i think the way chess is taught
players who around 1500 would say this
is immediately better for white i have
the bishop pair but as you can see off
the side and with black's leading
development black is doing okay for now
but the prospects can be very dangerous
for in terms of an advantage for white
yeah for sure uh this bishop d2 move has
definitely become popular because people
don't care anymore at the highest level
about uh
getting some sort of main line position
that has been played before they they
frankly don't even sometimes care about
advantage like if the computer says the
position is about balanced um you're
gonna get just an interesting game and
if you know the plans better than your
opponent by the way queen d5 just looks
like a straight up winning fork it's not
because uh black uh take place queen e7
i thought he took on c3 in this position
wow what knight c6 traps the queen that
is
that is amazing incredible so
but you know you've seen audrey's time
he's barely used any time so he knows
which moves are best
and
that is why he is able to play quickly
i'm sure he has studied some of the
different alternatives that black can
play and it seems like gelfin has played
into something that he understands right
now he's offering an exchange of knights
to open up his rook so in the topolof
game we had seen f takes g3 that would
be a completely terrible move now
because there is no rook but hg would
open up the white rook on the h file
what a position this is with attacking
prospects galore i'm worried about gal
fans king but the way galvan's playing
he's playing quite quickly it still
feels like he's in a relative comfort
zone i hate the look of the position but
i trust the player playing it so i'm
going to give gel fan uh the benefit of
doubt and i think we should go to the
nishikiri game against ju 1 june just
because that's a fifth and final match
going on in this early session here so
let's pull up this game and anish with
the white pieces against the
women's world champion and
all right just a pretty normal position
relative to what we've just seen in the
last few games
yeah this just looks like a
relatively straightforward queen's pawn
opening
i think this was some sort of
maybe like knight f3
d4 c4 e3 kind of a position but uh yeah
let's just quickly go through the
opening i guess see what uh
how we got here
um it i think there was probably some
bishop b5 at some point or yeah yeah wow
wow yeah
there it is
and uh okay isolate upon position okay
bishop e2 yet because black had already
castled okay so it's this thing i don't
know if you've dabbled here robert but
uh this is a very hot area right now for
uh
for for chess just kind of getting a
pawn structure game and not really
worrying too much about having
such a huge advantage or cutting edge
theory but just playing against the
hanging pawn structure which is the c
and d pawn structure that joe and june
has
with this knight just planted on c5 yeah
i mean these types of positions i feel
like when i have the advantage i never
win and when i have the disadvantage i
get in huge trouble and
probably lose so i i have to admit like
these positions they look very flimsy to
me from both sides the pawn e3 very
clear target the knight can come to f5
you can try to go after this pawn the
pawn c6 stuck in its tracks and then
with rooks coming to c5 later i feel
like you're in trouble so i really don't
have a great grasp on these positions if
i'm being honest levy uh but i don't
think that uh either player right now is
too worried but they're getting into a
blitz game only three minutes per side
now so it feels like a bliss game really
just based on where we are
wow i hadn't even realized i just
assumed that a lot of this was sort of
played quickly by a niche at least i
thought maybe the first 10 or 15 moves
or some sort of preparation wow
okay so yeah they literally have three
minutes to figure this game out i mean
yes they have two seconds bonus but
trust me you don't feel that when you're
down to about 10 seconds
no
e4 all right so it's a attempt to trade
queens potentially liquidate at some
point it says it's level i i think i
have to switch games here so okay uh the
vichy game is really heating up i don't
know how this position happened at all
but we're going to go over there right
now because i see a pawn on a2 for pablo
poncrotov i see an open h file a queen
on c2 and of course the engine says
zeros
uh is it queen a8 king c7 queen h8 queen
d1 or what or is just queen a8 knight b8
and you don't even worry about it what's
the move after queen a8
i guess knight to b8 looks pretty
reasonable to me this looks very scary
for white
i'm looking in this position i think
blacks is almost winning
yeah and look at the time this is what i
mean french experts they they know what
works and what doesn't in these
positions it's
very tough to stay sharp here
move by vishy yeah it's still even
how
i'm looking in this position i was like
you love me queen a8 how do i stop the a
pawn how do i deliver some attack and
the cool move bishop three because if
this rook were to leave the last rank
maybe there's also a queen f8 at some
point and the f5 pawn could be loose i
mean this looks
just and bishop can block the rook i
guess with bishop g2 but this is a mess
but isn't there like queenie four okay
so i but
is uh vicious playing to hold the
position right he's playing basically
not to get checkmated that's what i'm
that he's not i mean okay you're always
playing to win but it does not feel
right now like white is calling the
shots white is definitely not calling
the shots you're 100 accurate like
i it looks i see the eval so i know
white isn't losing but if you just
showed me this position i was watching a
blitz game i would think that white
loses in three moves i mean oh my god
kingy won the king returning to his
rightful birthplace on the on on the
home square but
somehow he's not mated i mean
queen d3 what is there some perpetual
yeah
i guess there's always queen d6
so queen f8 king c7 queen d6 i guess
but can i play knight
dl's queen c5 then yeah and then if the
king runs there's queen d6 and somehow
you're oh and queen a3 and it's just
always a draw
oh my gosh this geometry is amazing i'm
going to show that the queen d3 looks
completely winning but as you were just
saying queen check here queen check
again and if you block the knight we're
just repeating king b8 we have queen d6
and as you pointed out the queen can
always go back to a3 and through d6 and
things like that and that's how we can
make a draw that is
unbelievable
that is crazy uh wow that's
and it that that shows you the kind of
hidden punch of some of these french
positions is that they're really never
truly over i mean it it looked just
beyond miserable and pancrate have
turned it around and he's he's almost
checkmating white it's the perpetual
check that's basically saving white i
mean yes the game was kind of
theoretically always in the balance but
okay and i guess he's going to play
queen d3 and just make the draw from the
position of strength
right because actually black didn't make
the draw here with queen d3 bishop takes
d5 would have completely turned this
game around in white's favor so yeah
yeah so okay maybe strength is i guess
vichy was like kind of perfectly
balancing between attack and defense
right bishop takes d5 and
somehow his king would have been
completely safe i was crazy just vishy
covering up like this and
um still
you know still actively engaging his
opponent in
various aggressions despite looking like
his king is just on the verge of
just total decimation i think he will
repeat moves i i don't think he can not
repeat moves but can he i mean is there
anything else i don't think so nah he's
just going to repeat and i think punk
rock was looking like can i run with my
king somewhere like can i go king b6
after queens of king a6 and try to win
this game but that's exactly how you'd
lose games like this yeah you
you take a walk over there and your king
ends up in trouble because there's no
media checkmate for black so i think
that pancrato with the black pieces in
game one he should just take the draw at
this point be happy about the start of
the match and we'll see what happens
going forward so um should we insta four
other games going on i feel like yeah i
i feel like high stakes chess always has
some crazy dramatic moments like when
karate is going to like you know decline
repetition somehow like uh vish he's
going to try to play for a win but yeah
i do think that
he'll play king c8 and you know make the
draw so yeah let's go see what's going
on elsewhere how's the tepalav game by
the way did anything actually happen
there is topalov's trying to
win an end game what's going on that's a
joke i drew as soon as i clicked on it
look you could see depaul
veronica ran away and then paul's like
okay game's done it was a draw here it
doesn't look like it was too much
excitement at least compared to some of
the other games going on so let's keep
going down the line here yeah we have
the game between maxine vashila grav and
eduardo ituri zaga so let's go to that
one where
that bar is sky high and well this looks
as miserable as it gets for terezaga
yeah this uh this was a perfect
conversion by mvl
from attack to winning endgame and look
at the clock 5 to 12 seconds just 5
minutes to 12 seconds and it is the 12
seconds that really feels like 12
seconds and um
yeah that's because it's just you only
get two seconds of bonus time by the
time your clock is added and that's i
think that seems it yep white wins there
it is
that's game so maxine vashilograph takes
a one nil lead let's go back oh fishy
still going
what how how's that game not oh no they
just
i was like there's no way that game is
still going no it looks like punk rock
will spend a bit of time because he's
done a three and a half minutes and then
accepted the draw so that leaves us levy
with just the just as if this is not
enough the world rapid champion nerdy
rec abductor of the gold medalist from
the olympia taking on the former
challenger to the world chess
championship title
no dearbek is in a room that while poor
guy's last name is so long it goes off
the screen
[Laughter]
i mean listen i think he's got the
longest name in the entire event uh
if i if i may eduardo turisa gives him a
run for his money though uh and uh yeah
nojobrick looks like he's in a room
that's like um
could be like an album cover you know
like kind of like a like you see a cd or
something back in the day and best buy
uh and and it's just uh yeah he's got
this kind of cool i like his hey he got
he's got like the
he's got like the perfect background
there um and then levi have you seen
severance
no i have not seen severance it also
looks like it could be one of the rooms
in severance is that what was the genre
of of severance
it's
i don't know it's
it's like a serious uh show but like uh
it's with adam scott as it's funny as
well but it's like one of those kind of
uh
comedic shows with like real
serious undertones
well i was going to say he could have
like the miscav door you know how
misgive sort of had like has a whole
career with the door behind him yeah i
feel like you know the whole uzbek team
could just walk through the door at some
point or maybe it'll be his like his mom
and she'll get him some tea or something
i don't know it seems like there's many
things there's like nothing in the room
where is he
i guess there's a little furniture
cabinet over there maybe it's just a
chess office how do you think you become
an olympic champion you are in an
undisclosed location where nobody can
find you to disturb you
listen i that dude is like a
a a-list celebrity right now in
uzbekistan i mean after they won i don't
know i don't know if anybody knows this
but they went on this whole press tour
they were with the president they were
it was
it was wild stuff there so i i can
imagine probably top 10 most
most popular uh guys in uzbekistan right
now easily
also just he's a total sweetheart i ran
into the entire uzbek team at the
airport leaving the olympiad and i got
to talk to nordie back for a while and
he was just expressing his appreciation
for online chess all the opportunities
he's given him and he is just such a
courteous guy so he
is a devil on the chessboard but when it
comes to real life he's a really really
good kid yeah i just is absolute chess
savage uh gelfin here trying to get some
pieces off the board because white is
building up a really nice attack amazing
job here by notre dame of uh breaking
the rules of chess by not castling but
still
just having all sorts of defenses near
his king and this dark squared battery
really shows
the kind of deep rooted idea of the move
five bishop d2 in the nimso and you get
the dark squared bishop and then you
hang on to it for dear life and its
value goes from three points to like
five points five and a half points
and uh position is just really really
really good here uh toward the final
position with uh that we currently have
on the board i was just going to say
that you could take this bishop early on
in the game but now that's completely
behind us so um it seems that white is
going to have a long-term edge here and
well i guess levy we're going to take a
quick break just because uh you have to
keep on schedule here but we will be
right back for more from the chess.com
global championship sorry to leave you
hanging here but you can watch these
games yourselves as well but we will be
right back for more from the global
championship
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
the 2022 chess.com global championship
uh we are going to be watching and kind
of finishing the last remaining game
of our first round here
of the
group f as well as kind of a bonus
match-up in group age between eduardo
iturizaga and maxine buchelligraff the
position we have on the screen here that
we are not the ones playing uh this is
not rebecca abdul satura with the white
pieces taking on boar's girlfriend with
the black pieces and robert it's only
it's only gotten worse uh
from uh for for boris i think it's just
gotten worse and worse here
i mean since the beginning of the game
since bishop d2 as you're pointing out
right before went to break on move five
it's been a problem on the dark squares
for boris gelfand and now he's down a
pawn his king is not safe you see the
evaluation at plus seven and that just
means there's a winning tactic uh i
could see a move like bishop c4 levy
that actually looks
pretty nasty if it works out yeah that
looks like lights out there might also
be some bishop b5 and then i i i don't
know
i mean just in general yeah bishop c4
rook d1 does not save black i mean it's
a free rook but but uh probably rookie
six somehow and i mean it's on the board
and the eval stayed the same so there
you go i mean robert saw it instantly no
debris took his time he he also probably
saw it instantly but it's good to have
four minutes on the clock and just kind
of take your time i think this is it i
think we're going to see resignation um
i think boris's camera already resigned
that's the one tricky thing about
getting players from all over the world
on camera is that sometimes their their
cameras uh their cameras as we can see
they're
boris gelfin is a is a gentleman and a
handsome man he does not look like a
black square
so yeah i mean it's it's it's gone from
bad to worse i mean you know uh it's
yeah it's a rough situation here but
hopefully he can uh he can bounce back
by the way can i just say what a what a
damn game from no direct i mean my god
from start to finish this was just
amazing chess
yeah while we were working on some
technical difficulties behind the scenes
and just getting set for the next round
of action levy and i were talking about
this game and just marveling at the fact
that nordie beck i mean from start to
finish of this game he's been on fire
and he's gonna hope for
a knockout blow on the g7 square at some
point this knight on b7 is a donkey uh
just a great game
[Laughter]
i was just not expecting to hear that
sentence just the knight is a donkey i
guess what a queen queen c8 rook d7
something something
uh there's got to be something here what
is it
i guess
pretty good to me but queen c8 rookie 8
oh
okay well
filthy
yeah i mean sometimes it's kind of what
mvl did sometimes the easiest thing to
do was to just yep and that's it
wow just to show everybody the
conclusion rook d7 check picks up the
knight and i think that boris trusted
his young opponent to win two pawns
ahead in the end game it is plus seven
after all so a nice win for the reigning
world rapid champion and we do have the
other four matches going on so i just
picked up the game between zhu and june
and anish gary but i'm happy to go to
any of them
uh
yeah so that first game was a draw i
guess we never i guess we never really
got an official result for that game but
i see the half half so i see that um it
is in fact equal this is a very
interesting opening what what what is
what is this this is some sort of like
uh
maybe
i don't even i don't know what what was
the i was going to say catalan but it
did okay it was like some dc four okay
with some queens gambit knight bd7
robert i feel like you would be a fan of
the knight bd7 qgd like if you play
i i kind of am a fan of it and i've seen
anish use this before and it's an odd
opening but he plays this knight b6 move
he tries to cling on to this pawn on c4
hoping to continue his material edge but
he's giving up time in terms of
development and juwon june just takes it
right away because of this fancy little
trick here with queen a4 check so she
gives up the bishop pair but she's ahead
in terms of development and central
control so levi i think this makes
perfect sense from her perspective yeah
it's it's a weird it's a weird system by
black because you you take an approach
that's relatively offbeat
and and not played quite often but black
just gets an ultra solid position
and is kind of like come you know come
and get me
and well that's what white is doing
white is playing knight e4 knight c5
white has ideas like king h1 rook g1
like i'm you know i'm salivating at that
attacking opportunity i would be
salivating more if it was a three minute
game and my opponent was not you know
one of the top 10 players of the world i
would much rather hope to play uh
someone with a slightly lower title but
so game plans like that robert they work
better against an unprepared opponent or
someone that doesn't know how to deal
with various aggressions i think anisha
is more than well prepared but i have to
say having said all that i really like
white's position
yeah no joe and jun is playing a great
match thus far and i think people they
see the rating differential in these
opening rounds for the one seed in a
group against the eight seed midlay
almost took down dingley run yesterday
and juwon jun is fully capable of
beating a niche in a four game match in
fact she's played in champions chess
tour events and she scored some major
victories
in individual games so anish he
i actually
messaged with him recently and he said
to me just frankly he's like i haven't
looked at who's in my bracket because i
have such a strong matchup in the first
round so he's not taking it lightly
she's playing an excellent game knight
on d3 queen on c4 she just has more
active pieces here the one thing that
anisha's going for him levy is that
white does have these double pawns not
that big of a deal but if you're not
looking out for it in the long term
that's when it becomes an issue yeah it
feels like the only way to make progress
here with white is going to be with
either the move b2 to b4 at some moment
like prepared with a rook uh or with the
knight going to c5 right other than that
or i guess
uh
in in terms of pawn play b2 to b4
because if white ever pushes e3 e4 the
d4 pawn is extremely weak and you have
to have that kind of taken care of in
terms of peace progress knight c5 i was
going to say rook c3 rook b3 rook c3
would now hang a rook a move ago would
have been an idea but uh now that's no
longer possible and and each secures
control of the b4 square which he
actually controls four times which is
pretty crazy it's uh
like the one thing that's making him not
just have a much worse position is that
white just hasn't been able to expand
with b2 before but um
yeah she's just going to keep making
improving moves and
what's going to happen now we've we
talked about this in that game top uh to
paula veronica that was a long time ago
people might not remember also the show
was a bit early maybe they're just
getting here at some point in positions
like this you run out of improving moves
and either it's just a draw you just
shuffle back and forth and it's sort of
like unstoppable force immovable object
or you try to win
and in trying to win you expose yourself
to potential counter play and you don't
win and you might lose so we're going to
see what happens like this this position
is completely due in june's court like
she can do whatever she wants uh up to a
point and then she has to try to take a
risk to win or just make uh make a draw
not do anything yeah the central
question no pun intended is the move e3
e4
that kicks the knight out but you are
correct to mention this d4 pawn
immediately becomes a target so e4
generally speaking is a move that
carries significant risk because blacks
follow a plan especially if the knights
get traded is just rook d7 rook d8 pile
up all the pressure on this pawn d4 and
then maybe have a pawn break in the
future so uh i think that joe and jun
would be best off not pushing that pawn
i don't know what improving moves she
has levi so i wouldn't be that surprised
if she ends up just shuffling her pieces
and the position just remains balanced
yeah i
i agree i i don't know if it's worth it
to try to play something like knight c5
of course if you get that trade and then
the dark squared bishop for white makes
it to d6 that looks great like if we can
just
put that on the board it's obviously not
going to happen exactly how we want it
to happen but you know uh and we see by
the way stockfish isn't even thrilled
with that plan because black can i don't
even know what the idea there i get
queen before right queen before an ab4
is that the plan or
i don't i'm not even sure to be honest
what
stockfish being annoying
i guess though even with the bishop
coming to d6 it doesn't carry a threat
and that's the really frustrating part
about bishops is they can't move to the
opposite color so uh the knight can hop
around a bunch later in the game and i
think that while it looks really
annoying to see a bishop from d6 it
doesn't necessarily threaten anything
and maybe that's what the engine is
latching on to
yeah it makes a lot of sense uh the
knight if there was a knight on d6 it
would be you know just completely
crushing uh but it's
it's not completely crushing it's a
bishop and everything around it is on a
light square so it looks nice
but
is it usable i i'm not so sure i think
we have some more games let's let's take
a look at some other games
uh we have mvl we have obviously vishy
versus pankaratov
mvl got things done
with the wow he is already just
completely better here with the black
pieces as well what what was this was
this like uh
what was this god the openings are goofy
they uh was it h4a it was h4 i was gonna
say it looks like some weird early h4
and i mean you can't play h4 any earlier
in a normal opening than move three i
mean i suppose you could have done it on
move two or one but
[Laughter]
you know it's funny levy is that mbl
tends to be the most predictable
high-level player so the fact that it
says king's indian defense i was like
and then the position kind of looks like
the livestream benoni like you know that
ether is like i have to do something a
bit odd because maxime always plays the
grunfeld he always plays the night or he
plays these berlins all the time so the
fact that we have a benoni structure
means that iturizaga did something to
force the issue
yes i think one of the first people to
introduce this on a super high level
wasn't it grishook played h4 against mvl
and the candidates and uh that was a
crazy game it was like a benko gambit
style game it's one of the most
fascinating openings like i i tried to
learn it with white and then i just
couldn't understand it i kept again i
got excited when i moved my pawn to h4
and 10 moves later i was in a worse
position that was sort of the story uh
so yeah it's it's way too sophisticated
and imbalanced for me and yeah i mean
mvl
he dabbles in different openings but he
really dabbles in different openings
because chess at 2770 level is really
hard and when he's the favorite he's
going to play what he knows best and you
kind of see it like turzon is an amazing
amazing chess player but even he doesn't
want to go into the main lines he
doesn't want to you know he doesn't want
to have these uh
theoretical scrambles and battles with
mvl he'd rather play h4 and try to catch
him out somewhere where it's not so
critical and mainline style but
it's move 15 and black is better so
yeah he also looks like he has a
migraine i'm looking at her zaga he's
just like bent over at his hands on his
temples and that's what happens when you
play against these 2770s is like you
think you're doing the normal thing here
but then there's a rook on c4 why is
that piece there you want a knight right
this knight should be on c4 uh hitting
the d6 pawn and controlling the b5 or b6
pawn pushes but there's a rook there the
h4 pawn is hanging so castling won't be
so easy to make work your dark squares
are just completely under controlled by
this bishop on g7 the knight coming to
e5 and of course this pawn push to b6 or
b5 can happen at any moment opening the
b file coordinating brook and bishop
levy this looks really terrible for
ituri's i think if we keep this on the
screen any longer it's we could probably
get in trouble for some sort of like
harassment so um
yeah it's a it's a tough one i mean mvl
is just he's just a brutal brutal guy to
play against and like like i just said
if you try to take him out of theory it
can backfire so fast because he just
gets it like he just he just and what's
the time situation yeah it's three
minutes and it's only going to get worse
and
tourists got a tough spot here i mean
here's the truth he could battle back
here he could try to consolidate that h
pawn he could try not to get hit with b5
on the queen side there is a legitimate
chance he resigns this game in about 10
or 12 moves because
if it gets really out of control and the
time situation also gets out of control
you you just don't defend against mvl
when he gets going so um i think we have
we've been told that some other games
have started so yeah we can check in um
uh
i guess
wherever i don't know robert you want to
check in on vichy we got world champions
in every matchup basically wait what
just i just want to point out that they
didn't do anything they just shuffled
moves so no we're surprised that it says
draw because we haven't tuned in a bit
but all that happened was this
hey that's a look at that's a sign of a
solid commentator that's what i said
would happen yes you did
i was like they're gonna get to a
position and she can't make any progress
and neither can anish so draw
and there you go draw agreed one to one
in this matchup between juwon june and
robert
she did play king h1 by look her kings
on h1 but she never actually
[Laughter]
it was it was a
deke you know it was a fake out yeah she
was like oh oh oh i made you flinch oh
you know and yes do you think she did
the heisman post while she was doing it
as well you know i
i don't know what that is oh is this
the eyes and pose of football you know
when you deak somebody and you you give
them the oh is that oh i didn't know
that oh i know the heisman trophy i know
the pose that he has like kind of on the
that was that what he was famous for
exactly what that is yeah uh so i did
know i should have trusted myself i you
know i just thought for comedic timing i
would pretend like i not pretend i just
okay anyway what's what's going on in in
the matchup of um
current world champion and and uh
i guess
former challenger um
you know levi i have uh complete faith
in you so i'm gonna you know lift up
your confidence here you know what
you're talking about you got this buddy
so uh yeah you know with the heisman and
with the chess so
oh
yeah
did you just get instructions to hype up
my confidence that that seemed no no i i
just you know i felt like you know you
you said that about the comedic timing
all stuff and i was like yeah i got
faith in you i'm just letting you know
i'm an honest guy i'm trying to be
transparent oh well i i yeah i listen i
appreciate it it's it it's 8 a.m on the
dot here in new york so and then the
sun's out now so hopefully uh brain is
gonna start firing on some on on some
cylinders it doesn't feel good as a
commentator to like predict an entire
game basically it's like you're like ah
i've been here before i know what i'm
talking about having said that i got no
clue what's gonna happen in this one um
but i think notre beck is is a
professional he's going to try to take
the approach that aneesh had he's going
to trust his wide opening and i think
with black he's going to look to
stabilize
this one
probably also a d4 huh have we had like
any e4s except that french i guess we
had a sicilian in the nvl game but
mostly d4 yeah and i mean you can trust
boris gelfand to needle his way into
this position and we can go back to see
we got it it was a queen's game but
accepted but i'm just looking at the a5
pawn the b5 square i just feel like gel
fan has had so many instructive games
and positions just like this and based
on nordimex time
usage thus far levy that's it's not
concerning in the sense that he you know
he's plenty of time remaining but he's a
very quick player when he's confident so
i'm just getting the sense that boris is
going to put a lot of pressure on his
young opponent
yeah i think so i mean he has a
book called what what is it is it uh
secrets of something positional decision
making i mean it's literally a handbook
of
positions exactly like this where he
identifies
open files he identifies key squares he
like b5 c6 you know and potential pawn
breaks f4 f5 and wow look at this he's
he's not even taking the pawn in the
center back at all despite it hanging
with two different knights he thinks the
open file is more significant so
i feel like this is a very confident
boris right now you know what i would
play here with black what i would like
strongly consider it probably loses on
the spot but something like knight c3
because i feel like i'm gonna get oh can
i make that work actually do i have like
some d3 queen d3 knight seat you know
some like ridiculous tactic where i can
like drive my knight into the e2 square
um that would be awesome but i don't
think it works unfortunately i don't
think it works right here but it's
something to keep in mind right because
there are going to be positions where
you really desperately want to trade
queens because white's queen is aiming
for the b5 score and there's no rook c8
because the knight on a6 is loose so at
some point i would love to trade queens
which actually is a justification for
the move d3 even if the tactical
sequence doesn't work i could see a
future where a d3 makes sense but
queen b5 is
very tempting in these positions you
could of course just take back on d4
this is as boris of a position as it
gets
absolutely
having said that
i think one of the
stereotypes of young chess players is oh
you got to take them down to kind of
like middle and end game right you got
to you got to beat them that way remove
their tactics
i don't think that's the case anymore
and it's definitely not the case when
you're the world champion in a format
and
i think no dearbek is as good of a
defender as he is an attacker i i don't
even know what his specialty is his
style is good
like
he's good at the game you know what i
mean like maybe
a more depth analysis will show he has
certain weaknesses but like we're going
to see how he handles this position
and if he handles it effortlessly
what can you say right really what can
you say i think i'll be completely
transparent in the bracket preview i
had said that the winner of the matchup
between
if it happens node rebeck and uh and
vishy because i think they're on pace if
they win these matchups that person will
obviously win the group but
to do that you have to show brilliance
not just in preparation not just in
tactical play and initiative but
defending unpleasant positions being on
the receiving end of positional squeezes
and so on and we do see gelfin there has
his camera back although
unfortunately only 50
roughly of the facial surface area
well boris is one of those players i
mean if you've seen boris play over the
last decades he always is leaning
forward like one of those places takes
up too much of the board almost where
you're if you didn't respect him so much
and if you weren't such a great person
you'd be like hey dude can you like sit
back in your chair and give me my space
uh but you know he he's also encroaching
on nurvec's space on the board here and
look at that i was saying
you made this point that d3 could be a
useful type of move just to distract
white's pieces maybe get some trades
going uh but you know nerdy back says
i'm not going to give you this pawn with
the knight you're going to spend some
time let's move like queen takes d3 but
is it knight a5 yeah i was going to say
i think
everything that i just described came
back to bite so he is looking for a
tactical solution in an unpleasant
position and i'm not so sure it's going
to work here he had to
respect his opponent's threats a little
bit more he kind of tried to take that
approach of oh you're not going to take
my pawn well i'm going to make you take
my pawn but boris will just ignore it
it's completely blockaded and he will
just take on a5 get the knight to c6 the
very boris boris style move knight a5
knight c6 i mean it's
surgical it's very precise i think i
think that's the right approach here
gosh playing people like boris i would
love to because i respect him he's a
great player but i hate it you know it's
just like you're just waiting for that
moment where his position continues to
improve and nordibeck you talked about
his style
his coach from the uzbek team
yvonne sokolove said he's like carlson
in terms of his style where wow he can
he's very multi-faceted he can get that
squeeze going but i mean nobody likes
being on the receiving side of a
position where you're the one being uh
pressured and you just don't have an
active plan for yourself so i think
noting back has a lot to figure out here
i think we can maybe go to a different
game while he figures this out because
boris may very well uh snag this pawn a5
plant tonight on c6 and i think that
this task is going to be anything but
fun for the young uzbek superstar yeah
when you started describing what it what
it would be like to play boris i
literally sneezed i think i'm allergic
to being on the receiving end of this
chest
uh and yeah i mean just
very very unpleasant stuff here for for
naughty back who is he's well boris
hasn't found the move knight a5 let's
let's put it this way but if he does
it's going to be a serious defensive
task okay let's check in on vichy
before we check in on vichy uh levy we
just have to make an announcement that
raunek sedwani has defeated
former world champion investment depaul
in their second game so let's pull that
up quickly before we go to the game of
vishy and wait is that queen trapped
yeah wait what we didn't even see that
game what
was that game like 20 moves it was just
over 30 but it looks terrible for black
literally everything that could go wrong
in a position has gone wrong for tabalov
yeah he lost the battle on all three
sides of the board how did that happen
so could come let's just let's just
recap this game ronic didn't even wait
raunic is playing like he has an
appointment now yeah he was just
just a typical italian nothing special
going on robert
in in in my defense they probably played
half the game in about a minute right so
like like up until this point but then
what happened this has all been played
many times before so you see around
i started to pause not even spend a
minute and then upon push how did this
get so bad this is also normal like i'm
looking at this position and i actually
hovered over the game earlier while
we're looking at another and i saw this
position yeah it looks fine not a big
deal
and how did i get that oh that's how you
make one active move and you regret it
wow yeah and you that's it just
paralyzed
oh gosh
oh my gosh the pawn started storming
here because
oh goodness
that's gonna be tragic
oh my gosh like no moves for black just
completely frozen and after the rook
hits b7 he went rookie seven to save the
pawn which is an important one but his
queen got trapped that's
one move decided this game yep literally
the move c5 he was like i'm going to
solve my problems and raonic was like
yes and create about 10 more so
what a game
but you know what's weird this looked
effortless from raonic i mean really it
just looked like he played a bunch of
theoretical moves
pinned upon to a bishop and won the game
like
it's just crazy chess is brutal
i feel like depaul had just a simple
option many moves that were not c5 just
seemed to be completely balanced here
symmetrical pawn structure no weaknesses
for either side
but that he just pinned himself and
that's that's how sad chess can be when
you lose a game is like i made such a
normal looking move and then this
position collapsed
yeah wow the c5 is just that was it
and no questions asked the game was over
okay well rounduk said wani doesn't
matter how it's done he's thrilled to go
to a plus score against tepalov so okay
you mentioned the game between vichy
let's go right there because this
position is not looking good for the
former world champion whose king is on
h6
oh my goodness
what is going on
can we can we get a how did how did this
get this bad
i'm just going to pick a random move i
have no idea how this game went
looks
like a relatively normal position not
great for black or anything but
not
we took with the pawn
on f's oh there are back rank problems
levy so d5 would have been hanging if
you took with the rook
yeah wow so he has to play
some sort of uh g takes f6
oh gosh and then it's just a positional
night work nightmare everywhere
yeah and pankaratev is just gonna apply
the squeeze here yup queen f4 nice just
slow improvement not allowing vishy any
counter play on the queen side you gotta
love moves like king h2 right just like
a calm little move bringing the king
forward off the background oh
god
it's not good it's not good queen g4 wow
oh my goodness pankratov is just ah just
lights out this game yeah vishy
sacrificing a rook to try to get some
sort of
perpetual or
but i i don't think there's anything
yeah what's the problem there is none
with king to h3 and vishy is now down a
rook and he's dead lost on the clock on
the board and well look at him he always
kind of looks calm levy but you know
that he's probably quite upset about
what has just happened here yeah i would
have gone to
i'm not trying to say my move is in any
way better than uh vishwanathan anans
but i liked queen d1 with some maybe
vague hope of getting bishop f5 check
but
uh
i get it i mean he you know he's trying
to make sure that he keeps an eye on the
d4 pawn and
vishi's gotta he's gotta he's gotta go
up a lot he's gotta find
that
kind of like killer killer instinct um
that he's he's known to have and just
he's down one and a half he absolutely
cannot bleed away any more points so
um
if pancrate beats vichy i think we're
gonna have
no remaining perfect brackets like i
mean but agronomy is an excellent player
but
but just it's vishy
yeah like i i don't know what else you
know like pancrato is an excellent
player his only issue in this matchup is
he has an opponent like vishy that's
that's it
would be favored against many many
people so it doesn't seem like an issue
in this game in levy it's what we were
highlighting at the start of the show
that this is how strong the field is
pankaratov who many people haven't even
heard of but he's been the pro chess
league for many years he plays in all of
these online events title tuesday rapid
chess championships you name it he's
there and he is taking down
vichyanin in this game so he can win
this match and look at him on screen
here he doesn't look like a guy who's
phased by anything
he doesn't if he just looks like he's
chilling he's just playing a chess game
he doesn't he he might just be excited
to believe ishii you know that's uh i'm
not i i'm i'm not necessarily
cheering one way or the other but it it
is tough to see to see legends go down
and a guy like vichy you know
very easily uh top five top ten player
of all time for some people he'd be he'd
be number one you know um so it's
i mean his influences is amazing and he
i think he's looking for the
resign button
yeah he never uses that button so he
doesn't know where it is but yeah
he runs out of time because he doesn't
know where the resign button is because
he never has to use it good lord what a
flex
well vichy is going to have to bounce
back he did have an advantage with the
white pieces in that french uh in game
one and maxine vashilagrov he is still
playing at ituri zaga but levi it's been
bad for the player who now plays for
spain uh there's not gonna switch
federations uh but it looks just
miserable in this ending black has a
past c4 pawn and white has these double
pawns and e4 is a permanent weakness
this is
where did he used to play before spain i
thought he was always no venezuela
really
yeah oh my god for as long as i've known
him through zaga i thought he
represented spain i had no wow i did not
know that
well mvl represents france so i don't
think that's gonna change ever
um unless the us offers him a good deal
um no that's i'm not gonna make that
joke rookie two why does that move
oh it's just blunder knight f2 fork city
yeah
yep
and he he saw it instantly he you could
tell but okay again 20 seconds
doesn't it look like they're about to
fight each other
[Laughter]
they're both like yeah it's crazy
because gelfin sits so close and and
these dudes are just so far apart like
yo i hate this like
i mean does everything look like he's
enjoying himself
no
i mean he seriously looks like he's
about to get in the fight
and he's the nicest guy i think it's
cause his name is not on the screen
i think it's because we can't i think i
think it's really tough for us to handle
names that are longer than like 15
letters i i i don't know poor guy is
like you know what i yeah he doesn't
look thrilled he doesn't look like if he
wins this matchup he locks up like
another five thousand dollars you know
what i mean it
does not look pleased at all yeah he
said put some respect on my name and oh
he's doing the shirt biting
so yeah ralph mamidov was doing that
yesterday that's it's a good shred eric
rosen likes to bite his hoodie as well
and you know he's he's quite strong so
and there it is yeah i mean
and ituri saga has a similar problem
that pancrato is having in his match not
the score but just like
he he's in a spot where he he's just
playing a really damn good opponent but
krath of though is up he's up one and a
half half it to razak is a great player
but when mvl's like on fire like this he
just he's so tough to play against you
know what i mean like there are styles
that are
they they perform a certain way at the
top robert and then they're if you put
those guys against people 100 200 points
lower they steamrolled i think envel is
one of those guys like some styles might
not translate as much because they're a
bit more solid positional i feel like
mvl steamrolls
anybody outside of like top 50 top 60 in
the world yeah honestly i had a tough
time with my bracket because mvl
you know if he does going to win this
match up two nothing he plays sam sevion
and sam savion is an absolute beast he's
been in particular beast in the last
year on all these online events he's
often been number one at the end of a
rapid chess championship week he did
really well at champions chess tour
event so i wasn't quite sure how they
would match up i do have mbl moving past
sevien but then if nbl if chalk holds
and nbl plays into lavon and rhony and i
i felt like lavonne should be the
favorite there because of what you were
saying but i really do believe that
mdl's predictability is a problem for
him it was in the candidates when he led
in the first half and then struggled in
the second half when fabiano beat him uh
thanks to some great preparation so i'm
a little concerned for him if that
future matchup happens but nbl happens
to monster himself obviously needs no
real uh discussion points or
introduction because he's been a top
player for so long
yeah mvl against some some someone like
savion obviously will respect the
preparation i i feel like he will maybe
between moves 10 and 15 or 12 and 15
show up with just kind of like a maybe
third line
of of stock fish or third line of some
sort of preparation and take him that
way and see how he does because all
other things being equal you gotta you
gotta go with mvl but the the major way
to beat mvl it seems is to detonate 25
to 30 moves on the man right like and
fabiano's more than capable of doing
that against anybody not just mvl and
we've seen it and when that happens it's
it's insane remember that fabiano game
against uh mityarov recently in
syncfield cup that was unreal that was
just
what what was it was it stingfield cup
or was it rapid and blitz i or i think
it was in their classical game it was
this rogozin that was like 30 moves of
theory plus a queen sacrifice it was
unbelievable
yeah that was absolutely crazy and well
this one is anything but because it
looks like naughty back he's thinking
after bishop uh takes b4 check and black
will go up a piece temporarily if knight
takes b4 rook take d2 you have to take
this pawn but the problem is that this
knight just gets trapped over here you
can go knight p1 but that's not really
going anywhere after that so it looks
like black is just going to take two
pawns white takes the knight and we have
an end game with brook and four versus
rook and four
yep and the major problem here is is
boris's time
so i i think what happened was he had a
couple of critical decisions to make in
this game
and he took a little bit too much time
and ultimately made the wrong decision
what what did he do incorrectly he
played knight a5 surely right
in that critical moment where
we were sort of discussing
oh oh he did it this way
yeah
and that was wrong because what it
allowed bishop f8 after knight c6
ah yeah well just left c5 oh
right the bishop just was able to escape
and now this knight on c6 is loose so
knight a5 instead of queen b6 was the
way to go to keep the tension
and that's not the way to go no 95 is
definitely the best move and it keeps a
slight you know this is plus one plus
it's hovering it's you know thinking
getting more depth but it was much
better for white and i'm sure boris knew
that he thought that this uh his choice
in the game was probably equivalently
good but as we see all it did was force
this liquidation where blacks pass pawn
with fewer pieces remaining uh has been
a problem okay nerdwick takes an a5
rather than going for that pure rook end
game can't really fault him when he's
going to pass on d3
right
do we have
some other games or
[Music]
like is joe and jun and anish kiri in a
big battle no they're uh just this game
going
okay uh the i think they're waiting in
the next batch of games will start when
this one is over with as well so i guess
the players again nice break that's what
happens when you finish on the other
side yeah rounduk said one is just
chilling for like 40 minutes he's uh
which is really well deserved after that
win that's a huge win for him to i i am
i i thought he might have been a slight
favorite in that match right you got to
kind of go with like youth tactics like
less
less time on the clock online format i
mean it's a very close one but
uh you know and like you said in the
preview like sepal have struggled in
some recent events but uh the pancroat
of vishy one and a half half situation
is
pretty pretty crazy so huge credit to uh
paiva
yeah probably playing like a beast right
now uh roundup yeah i think he was the
favorite i'm guessing actually we can
get confirmation about the prediction
splits i'll ask the team to set us up
with that uh based on the brackets that
were filled out but i would imagine that
roundup was the favorite just because
he's a much
more familiar name at the moment not in
terms of the history books but in terms
of the guy who's playing in every single
tournament you can name so we'll get a
word from the team on that
yeah
yeah i think this game
will be over
relatively quickly
i think not your dearbek has to probably
just be a little bit precise with how he
handles white's outside pawn by the way
that d-pawn just survived
like no questions asked it just never
got captured he's still trying to
capture it for us
and
actually i gotta tell you 20 seconds on
the clock i don't think there's any risk
at all of white losing this but there's
a chance he flags
yeah he's moving really slowly we know
his camera has not always been in so
maybe he's even having internet issues
yeah he's one bar he has one bar of
connection boris galvan he does get his
internet back but he's having problems
oh this is gonna be so tragic i wonder
if not your back just offers the draws
on seeing that but i listen oh my god
he's down to three seconds he's gonna
flag
oh gosh
why is that such a blunder king d5 maybe
oh the knight g6 you get tempo and your
king gets in here but yeah it could also
just be knight g6 and then king d5 or
something but
maybe knight g6 e5
but the knight f5 i don't know
yeah it's not so clear i wonder if notre
dame's doing what you know he's going to
flag him
i was about to say oh
we got that 1.3 seconds left boris
gelfand the bullet machine nobody knew
that this guy could play bullet like
this oh oh this is yeah this is this is
really tough and and the craziest thing
is
he's not even he's sitting so far back
but yeah noisier going up 2-0 in in a
way that
unfortunately kind of demonstrates the
generational gap of players right i mean
this is not something that would have
ever happened when boris was not your
back's age
and it came out of nowhere i mean he
literally lost the game in the last
three or four moves and and i i i kind
of
when i saw the 22nd situation i got real
nervous for boris and unfortunately
that's what happens
and you know i think that this position
in the end well it was winning for black
and he was like oh boris didn't have
internet problems he wouldn't have lost
the game actually i felt like the
trajectory of the game was going in next
favor he was up a pawn in this night and
game it objectively should have been a
draw but if every objective best move
was played then we wouldn't even sit
down at the board so or play online so i
think that nerdy becky kind of defended
accurately and
deserved at least a half point it does
stink the way it happened but i think
that uh you know boris down to nil now
i don't even know what to recommend for
him because he's playing the world rap
champion yeah seriously i mean look it's
not the most exciting finish when you
watch one of the one of the best players
of the last several decades especially
in classical over-the-board chess go out
in an otherwise relatively equal night
end game
because of time but that's what you sign
up for right at the end of the day
there's no way to get this amount of
players in the same room especially in
modern era uh it's it's online for a
reason and unfortunately internet and
and the connection and the hand speed
and all of that that's that's part of
the game so no direct goes up two two
nil uh he is one of two people up two
nil maxine bashar grav also enjoys the
two-nothing lead against eduardo tour
zaga uh we are gonna take a break and
when we return it's game three in i
think every single one of these matchups
don't go anywhere
uh
[Music]
do
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
the 2022 chess.com global championship a
friendly reminder of what you are
watching today it is our second day of
the knockouts it's the round of 64. 32
qualified and 32 were invited we are
watching the entirety of group f and we
have a bonus dessert match-up for you
from group h between maxine vashila
graph and eduardo torizaga uh group f
robert thus far
uh we have roundok seduani with a big
win over vessel and zapala former world
champion nodes here back up to the tour
of having a two nothing lead one by way
of a dominant game and one by way of
slightly bad internet connection by
boris gelfand uh anish giri juwon june
absolutely nothing to choose between
them just a very solid first two games
and upset watch pavel punkaratev
is currently beating boschwanathan anand
and that is quite shocking so
um
i guess we have also some more bracket
information to go through as we kind of
give you a reminder of what even group h
is all about
group h is
a match up here between at the bottom of
your screen you see bottom left-hand
side you have mvl versus interrupt zaga
and the winner will move on to face sam
savion who defeated rasmuswane
and i think group h will conclude
tomorrow or the day after uh i am not
responsible for group h so i'm actually
not 100 sure robert your impressions
thus far
group f
well it's been an awesome set of matches
for sure
we've seen
we just are getting games going right
now but joo and jun she's holding steady
against nishikiri no match-up can be
taken lightly and i guess the most
surprising thing to me of all
even more so than poncratz of leading
vishyanan is the fact that 64 i believe
of people uh that's right said that
tepalav would beat roundup sidwani i i
could have sworn it would have been
raunic as the favorite player in that
matchup but uh people were going with
the legend yeah i i completely agree
that's what i that's what i said i mean
it felt a little bit strange to to bet
against tepalav but
such as such as life i mean there's
nobody can really beat father time and i
feel like ronnie sedwani give him a few
more years he's gonna you know he's
gonna be up there i don't know what his
classical rating is right now but it's
i think it's i think it's quite quite
good we see here joe and jun playing
this
uh very
challenging variation a5 and bishop a7
and i think there was a game nojirebek
actually played with white
and that was against hare krishna in the
olympiad where he played bishop g5 got
his bishop chased around and then got
pancaked it was the only game that he
lost and it was not pretty so i
is bishop g5 okay so he does it this way
now robert you know way more about this
than me so
can you tell me a little bit about like
why white would play bishop g5 why why
wouldn't like bd2 in this game
well first of all that was a great
reference and i was
sitting right near that game because for
two rounds of the olympiad uh i replaced
john donaldson gave him a little break
from the playing hall as uh the captain
and so i was sitting right next to that
game and i watched it unfold and
he did get
absolutely flattened by hari krishna who
is a stellar player obviously and yeah
the bishop on g5 going in this manner it
does cause black to extend the pawns on
his king side uh but oftentimes with his
knight coming to g6 it's not really that
big of a deal and actually helps black
gain space and control of key square so
that's why a niche instead with knight
d2 and d4 um the bishop doesn't
necessarily want to develop so soon
because it can go to bishop g5 litter or
maybe it sits on e3 but i think anisha
is prioritizing central control versus
bishop development
yeah now
with this
center pawn on d4 that anish has
what exactly is the plan like is is he
gonna take on e5 at some point if he
does take on e5 does he have to trade
off the dark square bishops
right like is he gonna have to play
bishop e3 at some point
i guess he says no it put his knight on
c4 and
and that's the thing that's pawn a5
right it normally spawns on a6 we don't
have to worry about it but there might
be a time where that pawn is under
attack and can in fact be captured so i
like the way anisha's handling is he's
done kind of nothing right he's just
made pretty standard moves but i'm
starting to appreciate his position
because i feel like um he goes back to
f1 so what do i know you know i'm like
going knight c4 getting active he's like
yeah let's just go knight f1 we're chill
this is a declaration of hostility by uh
baju and jun i mean knight h5 that has
bad intentions the knight is going to f4
and i even think anish had a game in the
final match up in one of these online
recent events
where he lost in a very similar way i
don't remember he might have actually
had a decent position but
someone put a knight on f4 against them
and they won and they almost made it
look easy i almost feel it was aaron
guys here prague but
uh
i i would not enjoy playing this with
white like just having this knight here
standing there the bishop on a7 kind of
sniping out my center and my f2 pawn i
don't like these positions with white
that doesn't mean anything they're
obviously completely okay to play but
uh okay she just takes the bishop so
that's that's a little bit more relaxed
but is that the right approach by black
because i i don't know i mean knight was
so good on f4
i guess she was worried about bishop
retreating f1 and then uh white just
continuing development and that's the
thing the knight f4 looks imposing but
sometimes you can just play around it
and say looks can be deceiving not
actually doing all that much but with
the bishop pair that's also not that
impressive what is your light square
bishop doing it has no good diagonal to
work with so i am starting to appreciate
anish's position more uh you with the
994 i agree with you though i was a
little concerned about the prospects but
now i feel like it's just a normal
looking position where a niche can start
expanding over here in the center
i am a little bit concerned about
something like knight g5 maybe uh and
then trying to get that bishop to damage
the structure queen b5 also looks really
good because black not right now just as
a kind of concept
because black doesn't have the pawn on
the traditional a6 square right now we
talked about i don't know what the best
best plan of action here is for black
but i'm also trying to calculate the
move d5 okay she does c6
that's fine she wants to go b5 she also
prevents the move
uh queen b5
yeah
tough spot here i don't know what's next
for a niche
i'm into that move for sure you know
takes away b5 makes d5 less appealing
because what white would like to avoid
is some kind of position like this where
eventually black gets f5 in you can
already see the evaluation turning in uh
black's favor so you use like a really
bad specimen
yeah
and anish plays
b3 a pretty mysterious move but also the
best move so
interesting choice i get i
i guess rook 81 otherwise he would have
lost the a pawn somehow
i wasn't even looking at that but that
pawn was hanging that's right uh if the
pawn didn't go to b3 but it just looks
weird because you're inviting black to
play a4 at some point
yeah i i i guess that was just that was
just the approach and then maybe he'll
play rook 81 c4 and just have a really
kind of nice crown center and if black
ever takes in the center that's
really just an admission of a bad
position i mean your d6 pawn is going to
be horrible and it's it looks like a
moroxy bind but it's it's not it ain't
that and in those positions black gets
counter play here
with the exception of a5 a4
black doesn't really have a whole lot
but even a5 a4 is substantial anyway i
think this game
this is like a this feels like a
classical chess game you know the
position is a bit slow but developing
let's jump around and see what's going
on
if we can
okay let's go to the topology game
against ronix and wani because ronik won
a nice game in
bishop e3 c5 bishop e3 in the game was
pretty much over as this one is
following the path we predicted but
let's go on to this game because i saw
pawns on g5 and h5 levy and i you know
how you do guess the elo if you showed
me this position and said guess the
e-love of the players in this game i
would not say uh former world champion
veselyn topalov and rising sensation
ronald's iguani
yeah what
what is going on i mean you might as
well play f5 as well
okay he decides to put a bishop there
what what was the opening some sort of
reversed
it's probably c45 yup
robert what is going on at the with with
all these englishes you know chess is
like art in the fact that you can look
at it and completely not understand it
but pretend like you do just to have
conversations with people and on a
serious note i just feel like it evolves
in different ways like you know there's
like all these different art periods of
history the current meta is to play c4
e5 with white and and do whatever the
hell you want a3 d3 e3 what's going on
all right can you can you translate this
grandmaster stuff to me i don't get it
i i think that
it's kind of this amorphous position
where it doesn't give either side the
clearest of plans and
you know in response to this c45 stuff
people are taking the report approach
let's just throw my pawns up the king
side over here gain some space but i am
often concerned that you've over
extended and if you look at the clocks
it's not like ronald's in time trouble
but he is spending
almost five minutes for the first 10
moves and that is very unlike sanwani he
is a very speedy player so i think
wesleyan is doing the proper thing he's
avoiding mainline theory because rauna
is very well prepared and that allows
him to comfort zone instead he's taking
us back to like 1990 and saying hey you
were like
your parents might not have been alive
at that point and he's just trying to
control the center and i mean this looks
very solid for white even if it's
unspectacular
yeah i think there's a few things at
play i i think it's like oh he's gonna
play a sideline against me i'm gonna get
aggressive
you know i won the last game uh i won
game two it's a big confidence boost let
me just get aggressive and and beats
paul's like oh yeah
come on come and get some like where and
and he has like a hedgehog style
structure right he has a bunch of pawns
on the third rank uh and against this
kind of like structure you generally
have to
poke the right way but if you don't
you're gonna hit spikes and to be honest
with you i don't know what black's
poking move is like everything is
covered here and as you said you play g5
h5 now the burden of proof is on him
right no proof is uh just
like okay prove it because if you don't
why'd you push all those pawns in the
first place white's gonna play moves
like knight e4 which attack g5 and maybe
try to get something to the c5 square
like knight c4 right now looks like a
very strong move to me but
who knows
that's a great idea he might play bishop
b2 first but the knights come to e4 and
black does want to put pieces in the
d-file and the knight on e4 says yeah
you can put a rook on d at some point
but you're not actually threatening
anything the pawn d3 is well defended so
bishop e7 by roundup the this is why
it's a bit misleading to just have the
engine on it says minus 1.2
black is doing just fine i don't think
levy or myself were claiming that white
is better but this doesn't have the feel
of a position that's necessarily better
for
black castles queens i guess he had to
castle in that direction if any but i
feel like at some point b4 might be a
worthy pawn sacrifice
yeah
wow
um
i'm in shock
i have to say that for for all of the
i guess concern
over the way ronnik has played this
i don't really know what white can do
here if white plays knight c5 you just
take and then take on d3
and
if white castles long here
not really
what you want though right it feels it
feels just loosey-goosey
it does
but uh yeah i don't know
i don't know i mean what what is what is
white's next move though
what are you just like bishop e2 what's
black's plan is he gonna move his bishop
and play f5 that actually might be a
a very good plan that's exactly yes
okay
i'm starting to buy it more and more i
mean all these pawns are just
pushing up the board here and white has
no space
but when you do play f5 knight c5 now no
longer hangs the d3 pawn right because
the f pawn would be blocking the bishop
on g6 but even then black would play f4
or something and
cause you a bit of a headache
speaking of headache
how was it tourisaga doing
last time we checked him he looked like
he was having a migraine playing mvl and
to be honest who wouldn't
okay he is once again down three minutes
on the clock but this position is equal
but
he needs to win
yeah that's why he has a headache that's
why he's down on time a draw is a loss
for him so
this is not the type of position you
want because white controls the only
open file the fully open file over here
if you trade more pieces good luck
winning the resulting end game
no this is uh
you're playing maxine bashir legrove and
you have nothing in particular to attack
yeah
yeah nbl knows what he's doing playing
with black
against mvl and being down to nothing is
uh is a tough i mean playing black at
this level and being down to nothing is
tough
um
okay well i think yeah i think mvl has
control here he's gonna play a bunch of
really fast moves like that oh oh wait
what did he blunder i know oh is there
bishop e4
oh
and knight takes b3
oh my goodness mvl style just came back
to bite him i thought he was going to
play f3 or something but
oh no
oh yes itarazanga might just
take that take on b3 the queen comes
back we get uh two pawns in a rook and
we're talking about from each other it's
against perspective two points of the
rook for the two-minute pieces and you
can see it's just much better for black
with this healthy pass pawn on b4
yeah if i mean if he
is it live or did are we just anal he
won bishop c6 oh my god see that's the
sign of a defeated player i mean i saw
bishop before in in in a second and i
but i'm relaxed i'm not stressed right
yeah crazy and i guess there was that he
robert isn't that it's a little bit
upsetting to see right just just from
the standpoint of like
you give it to ryzaka that position
against any random person in title
tuesday he plays bishop before that's
what i feel like
yeah i think that if this were game one
he also plays well
maxine probably wouldn't blunder bishop
before but right if that was available
to him i think utiliza finds it and uh
you mentioned the you know ludwig's
tournament when you could see the evil
if the evil bar was present obviously he
tears out would see it in a millisecond
so that's what people tell you like all
you need is to see the evaluation maybe
even once in a game and that changes
exactly um how you see the game and how
you play it so he may get his knight
into d4 all this great stuff but there's
just not much to play for in terms of an
advantage if the knights get traded
you're never gonna win uh if you're not
gonna get to d4 you have some chances
but i mean i think at this point levy
it's all about what could have been not
what's to come
yep
completely agreed
and i don't think mvl is going to allow
a second chance like that i'm not even
sure he he realized he allowed it in the
first place he had absolutely zero
reaction but maybe he did maybe he did
it's very common to play a move that was
bad
and uh
and and then just immediately see it
right after but okay let's let's keep
going let's keep keep looking how is
vishy doing that's our upset alert
okay i'll bring up vishy in his game
against pancrato here
and as you see on screen material isn't
a pawn to the good for vici he's got an
extra pawn here but from chrysler just
doing this thing he played the french in
game one and now he played the philidor
so he is choosing openings that are not
often played at the highest level and
if the evaluation is any indication of
what's to come i mean he's doing it with
success
yeah the
uh
the
philidor is not
really a bad opening wow he played this
philadelphia he didn't even play the
philidor that's like knight bd7 i i
think that one's called like hanhem or
something well he played this villain or
oh my goodness robert i feel like we're
in like the 19th century
[Laughter]
you think philidor himself is playing in
this game
yeah seriously like the guy who invented
the opening i mean yeah this opening is
just a calm point seven for white
and
it's up to it's it's going to be up to
vishy to win it yeah look at punk roth
of just getting aggressive
he was even he was even like much better
for a move apparently
yeah i guess uh complicated but better
for black and what in the
what is this game like
black is just better
yeah wow
wow
i guess just i don't know
i i feel like if someone at like a live
event like uh todd steel you know india
rapid and blitz played the filter
against vichy he would beat them in 25
moves i i just i i think it's just
something a little bit different about
the
the online format and just relax and
it's it's different man it really is and
i feel like the top guys will all say
that too online is interesting but live
class like over the board
it's a totally different focus and and
uh type of playing experience
you know what's interesting is that
moment where c4 was played and i wonder
if poncratov he looked at this position
he thought okay my position is good but
i don't have a clear plan and with the
d4 pawn uh being targeted so many times
a knight coming to f5 these pawns
marching up the board for white i wonder
if he actually had a sense of
nervousness like okay if i don't do
something now if i don't trade queens i
might just get steamrolled on the king
side and i don't have the same prospects
um over on the queen side so he trades
queens in this manner recognizing that
vichy wouldn't play rook to d2 which
does defend the palm but walks into c3
and more activity for black so instead
he goes back to d1 and levy the position
here where we have an end game it says
like a slight pull perhaps for white but
are you believing that because
frankly i'm not
i don't know the only thing that white
could seemingly
in my mind take advantage of is the
pawns on the queen side like somehow
poke at them with b3 or a3 or c3 i mean
think thank god i don't have to make
that decision probably not b3 because c3
gets super weak but
that was my first instinct and then i i
figured i would have a little bit more
flexibility that way but
yeah i i don't know man like robert if i
gave you one second to play a move here
with white what is it
i would probably go like a rookie six
yeah right rook d6 right like you is
that really the best move like i
i don't know and then black can just
play like i don't know 95 97
[Music]
yeah they're all these like problems
where if we even get this actually just
he goes for it so let's put this on the
board your pawn's not going anywhere and
if things happen with f6 king f7 and so
on this pawn actually could just become
a target a liability rather than an
asset and the e-file is open for the
black rook so
yeah i'm not believing in vichy's
position and
pon kratov i mean the guy is just
playing like an absolute madman i mean
every opening choice from him from the
black side is like would you really do
this if you sat face to face with vichy
the answer may be no but he's doing it
now and it's working out for him
yeah this is amazing stuff i i was
wondering if white's position is
improving if the pawns on the king side
were on h2 and g2 and i feel like it is
right because the bishop is far more
stable
and that allows a lot of flexibility but
because your whole side is completely
exposed like rookie three rookie four
all these moves create problems for
white
i
vishy could get in trouble here it even
feels like
i'd rather black yeah this d6 pawn is
blockaded by the knight with this rook
as you were saying barreling down the e
file this king walking to e6
i don't see how white could be better
here it says zeros but that's
misleading and bishop e1 okay he's using
your plan great move
yeah that that's a that's a sick move
what a move um i wonder c3 here or a3
yeah one of those moves for sure because
you can't just let black do whatever he
wants and right now there's back rank
problems uh black's pawns are defended
and with rookie four
on the agenda you need to play a move
like a3 he goes forward
yeah and if he can get his bishop around
to c7 he's gonna have a nice time in the
end game but
black is still gonna go rookie four and
black is still gonna put a king on e6
and i
there's literally no way through for
white
the white is gonna have to rely on a
king walk i think later in the game well
actually that king walk might happen
quickly because if you take on a3 this
king goes to b2 and c3 and this pawn
over here could be in huge trouble that
that might actually be what happens like
that if if pancrato doesn't quite
realize how white will make progress she
will literally play king b2 king c3 and
just walk all the way to c6 and then
and then maybe white is once again
playing for a win white's problem though
is is these pawns
um these g and h bonds
yeah but
g and h pawn's a problem but
some of these pawns are probably going
to fall and then it becomes a race and
bishops usually are better than knights
when they're pawns in both flanks right
because they're long-range pieces so
i don't know i really didn't like vici's
position at first and then he makes this
bishop e1 move retreating moves the most
difficult to find in chess and now
suddenly i'm like hmm okay i could get
behind this
yeah
uh we see rookie four there
uh we're a little bit delayed from the
chat i don't know maybe like 30 seconds
or something but we it seems like uh
anisha's winning by the way so
maybe we can pop over there to see
what's going on uh it seems like you and
jun did blunder
but i don't
oh that
this is this doesn't even look like the
same game
you know there's a pawn that was on e5
and it's no longer there because after
pawn takes uh is it just queen takes e5
is it that simple can just be that easy
where checkmate one is threatened and
the knight is hanging
yeah how did it get this bad it seems
like even before 95 it looked extremely
promising
uh here the position okay so yeah he
used the central space advantage he
pushed through
and
the trades occurred and yeah black was
just totally restricted knight f5 was
played
oh d6 is falling yeah so it it's kind of
it's kind of what we what what we were
describing you you had mentioned that
black has the bishop here but it's not
really clear what it's doing and well
five moves later
six moves later and we see the
breakthrough and yeah and she's going to
go up to now and there it is anish is
not even putting the shirt in his mouth
he's holding it in his mouth with his
sorry uh he's holding the shirt just in
his mouth he's not even like putting it
there you know like ralph
and uh
saga they you know they need to say he's
your own
well
and each needs to be a role model he's
got two young kids and if he is biting
on his shirt what's he supposed to say
to his two sons when they start doing it
right wait so are you saying
it's a good thing or a bad thing that
he's not i'm saying he's not biting
because he's like you know i'm just
gonna gently place my
face on my shirt rather than going for
snack time
okay that makes sense
uh anisha's like uh he's he's very he's
got a very red light on him seems like
very
very intense concentration here as he
looks to uh to put the game away
probably can win in a couple of ways g4
g5 f6 but that's not
i feel like that's not a niche style d6
gives me a niche vibes yeah also does he
have a new hairstyle like did he just
get a haircut i was i was gonna say that
but i didn't want to objectify you know
but but yeah yeah yeah i mean listen
anisha kind of guy like you can talk
about like a haircut you know he won't
get offended but yeah i think he got a
fresh cut yeah no and i mean i know
anish quite well and i i don't recognize
this look from him
so he's also really focused right now
you can just see him uh intently trying
to find a plan a winning plenty he knows
he's winning and june june also looks
like she knows he's winning but you
don't want to mess up these kind of
advantages
uh out of curiosity was g4 g5 f6 like
totally winning for white there because
he did go d6 but i'm curious what what
what the engine uh yeah or yeah i mean i
know if you want to give me your
blessing this looks also completely
winning but it doesn't feel like it's a
niche style so
the engine gave it its blessing and i
agree with you completely though like
it's winning and i'm sure nietzsche
knows it's winning but why does he need
to push those pawns if he doesn't have
to and expose his king so what's the
material count it's a rook and how many
pawns
a lot it lost count
just three it looks like five that's
it's yeah it's more than enough it does
feel like five feels like he has all his
pawns is he gonna is he gonna have a
rook v8 check if this bishop moves is
that what's about to happen that's
filthy
it's uh just going to be winning you
know you can get a back rank
problem
so yeah niche has this
he's going to go up two to one i'm just
gonna just hover over some of the other
game to see if we need to move elsewhere
um
what is going to paulov's game i think
we have to go back there sure because
vessel in against raunch is not going to
be
invested in his time this tournament is
coming to me
oh my god yeah this was
good lord this was unbelievably
one-sided
this is this is pretty crazy because
that first game i think a lot of this
match really was psychological we we
talked about it going in right in that
first game ronic sort of held serve he
was solid he was relaxed and he
equalized that second game gave him a
massive confidence boost look at the way
he played this game i mean he just came
in throwing haymakers like he played
this game like somebody had bet on him
to win in the third round
and he was just gonna win in the third
round he was just gonna put it away uh
and
g5 h5
and he just never looked back and look
at this finishing touch g3 distracts the
queen from the bishop on b2 so the queen
will have to take on g3 and the black
queen can take this bishop and you're
just up a piece and that's game over so
uh
what a performance by ronic sedwani
vessen tapalov is one of the best
players of all time there's no question
about it but right
here in today's game today's match
it's been all raunic ever since c5 was
played by topalov
yeah seriously it's that seemed to
really have a of a big impact on this
game as well he kind of chose a very
tentative and slow opening and raunch
played in a way that i've almost i don't
think i've ever seen
people play like that before have you g5
h5 bishop f5 like against passive
english setups that was crazy and he
made it work
passive in topolov don't belong in the
same sentence so he pays the price you
could see it on his face
apparently vishy anand is also doing
work right now he's moved on into an end
game where he's up a pawn so i'm just
going to bring that game up quickly uh
the one between uh anand and pankaratov
because it looks like depaul's time this
event is coming to an end and vishy well
he is just up up how did he he is a
magician
yeah i was just i was going to make a
comment like i wonder where his king is
and it's just
it's just chilling
yeah wow
okay so oh gosh i guess paul carter just
never took the pawn because he was
worried about the rook coming down the e
file
yeah yeah uh
wow that went swimmingly it's like that
move yeah it is but h5 was the big
mistake i guess just king e6 first and
maybe 95 after after age five fishy
takes and then rook comes back to e1 and
look at this move that's what punks have
missed
yeah that's that's tough that is a tough
one uh we remember we talked about that
deep on being useless for a while well
oops
weren't we wrong yup and
obviously if knight takes pawn there was
rookie seven check i think there was
i'll show that because i've drew an
arrow but it's better to show on the
board check winning the piece game over
so instead uh he went rook d4 but now
levi it's an extra pawn and i you know
we have the engine on we have the eval
bar over there we don't have the moves
that are supposed to be played we'll
just watch vichy do this because you
don't become a five-time world chess
champion and a former world rapid
champion to boot if you don't know how
to win these kind of end games and he's
going to make it look easy even though i
think a lot of people at first glance
it's only one pawn aren't all working
games drawn no they're not being up upon
is good having multiple pawns together
is good and
uh he has you know c and b are kind of
together if you get rid of the c pawn
also
black has no pawn mobility that's a
major problem or frankly any type of
mobility because the c3 pawn is so weak
if the c pawn was on c7 how much closer
to a draw is this
still has i think has to be lost just
because of how great this rook is on
this the fifth rank because um i guess
the way black would try to draw that
which levy's questions upon c7 if you
get rid of these pawns on the king side
then black's king can venture over
towards the center but in
saint louis we saw yonder palm she take
down ali reza farouja and i think that
there's even material but white had so
much more activity that was nepal in
that game so he was able to uh win that
one and here vishy would like to play
king a2 his pawn is hanging so first i
wrote c5 and if this work comes the e3
then the white king just ventures out
yeah this is a big win for vichy
he gets it done while he doesn't quite
get he's he's on the path to getting it
done right now
good thing he has four bars of
connection we don't see it on the
current screen but that's all right
what
what is happening what oh my goodness
apparently he made a mistake we'll go
back right here the king c1 is the
obvious move but apparently king a2
that's the way to go and if rook takes
c2 then the king just comes to b4 and
then you win this pawn and your pawn
runs oh no
oh no
and
so pancroat of doing his best here
and the king now
is very close to this b-pawn and this
rook can come to d2
oh no that was right rook d2 and then
vishi's gonna have to grab the jeep on
and just sort of run
how
rook pawns are the absolute it's funny
how we love rook pawns when they're used
as a decoy and distract the opponent's
pieces but they're so bad when it's just
the only pawn remaining so even if you
get a rook g7 and a pawn all up to h7
the black rook will sit on the h file
behind it and you're not going to win
this game
this is
this is crazy
what a hold potentially here from from
pancrato and and by the way this is got
45 seconds
oh my god that actually probably is part
of it it's part of the reason why vishy
made a mistake in this ending is he
didn't have that much time probably got
a little bit nervous oh
i want to blend it right back
yeah he blunders but what it what is it
is it b6 or h6 if he's got 30 seconds
time is ticking which one is it
i wonder if he even well actually i
played b6 because the problem is you
play h6 right give me a 2 there might be
king c5 so in b6 i can keep going to b7
so the pawn this pawn gets advanced
first and then the second pawn can run
h6 king c5 is so brutal so b6 rook b2
but isn't there like rook b1 and then c2
somehow but rook b2 doesn't threaten
rook takes b6 because of rook g6 checks
but maybe there's king d1 ah
that's probably what he missed
or
i don't know but he obviously missed
something because when you take the pawn
you're basically allowing your opponent
to push and you would have probably
expected b7 but the fact that rook b2 is
not a threat is so sneaky
and that's such a critical difference if
we can bring up analysis board really
quickly here we can show exactly the
difference because if the h-pawn had run
instead
uh here then this rook comes to h2
threatening this pawn push and you could
take this pawn there's no skewer there's
no check on the sixth rank after so as
we get to the live position here it look
wait what he missed it no how what
what oh no vichy
time trouble
wait what is going on
oh
it's just a draw that's it and vishy is
really upset you just saw on his face he
looked to the side
he's just like what happened there let's
go back to that moment there is vichy
will have to recover emotionally heading
into the last game but vishy knew he was
winning that's the thing is we saw at
this point rook c1 check
king e2 and after c2 he goes king d2 and
look at that
somehow king d2
is not the move is it rook is it b7 or
rook c7
what in the world how is that not the
move is it rook c7 after after uh
in instead of king d2 oh my gosh
wait
no i'm so confused now no but but here's
the draw king d2 is the draw but is rook
c7 winning uh
yeah is it rook c7 it's not rook c7 so
that means it's got to be b7 right
but then rookie one and then you run
away no that's also a draw what
so the impressive elimination the only
other move is king d but why is that
winning yeah what what's the difference
when you could still play rook h1
b7 and and uh c1 is not a check
oh my gosh this is
unreal that is
that's the critical difference the king
on d3 as you're saying is not check when
you promote so if you promote and i
promote it's promoted with check so
black is going to get checkmated
oh my okay how can you follow anybody
for that mistake
yeah that is so crazy i mean you saw my
my top two candidate moves were also
draws it just goes to show you like
i mean king d3 is not human because you
you never want to allow like a check on
the back rank it's just not a human move
to go up in that position
wow
it looks the same because if rook h1
came here it's the same exact position
as in the game that's actually what
happened so
oh my goodness king d3 this is very
instructive but i would there's no
player in the world that i would expect
to notice that difference of 20 seconds
on their clock even if some people find
it
okay we're going to go to the abducitar
of game both players and typical gelfand
who is down
two games tonight he can't afford to
draw levy he's doing well with the black
pieces yeah he's he's doing super well
this looks this looks
horrible this looks like a disaster of a
position to play
with uh with white here oh gosh but he
gets out of it oh yeah that yeah
g4 was a great move but it was nerdy
back
that was yeah yeah and uh that's it i
mean those are breaks up two nil yeah we
got here just in time but uh
yeah these these these these young guys
are just so tough to beat in scrambles
and you could
at some point think about taking
especially if these pawns are about to
get traded or queen g4 watch out for
that at some point so king goes back to
very smart play by nerdy bank
yeah and this is uh this is it i mean
yes kelvin has a beautiful battery but
unfortunately there we go that's a queen
trade offer
not your back is uh
oh gelfand just i apologize uh
yeah the queen trade constantly being
offered and i guess yeah we're just
gonna get a rep position oh no maybe not
but you can't can't leave the seventh
rank otherwise you get right
all right next pre-move pre-move queen
j7 g7 nope no you're back take that pawn
take on g7
wow he doesn't want to be material down
when the draw is secured
that's it so
uh once this game finishes
which it will after a bishop moves and
then a pawn gets pushed
right now g6 there it is no dear back is
through to the round of 32. gelfand oh
wow he is uh he's he's quite distraught
yeah he had uh some really really good
positions in the last two games
and no wins to show for them but um
listen it was always going to be tough
to to bet against an olympic gold
medalist one of the fastest rising 2700
rated players in the world
uh and um
the champion of the world in rapid i
mean really what can you do and you earn
results when you have bad positions and
g4 is such a great move look at this you
have a problem with your queen your
knight g5 looks like a knockout so after
g4 you can still play knight g5 but it
comes at the cost of a queen trade so
when you win this rook on e1 you get to
a position with opposite colored bishops
and you will win the second pawn but
white can just give it in this way with
split pawns here uh opposite-colored
bishop positions almost always drawn
even when you're down two pawns like
this so that's what nerdy beck had
cooked up and gail fandom you gotta
always praised the legend unfortunately
his tournament has come to its
conclusion
yeah there's so even some positions
where g and h together are a draw
because the like opposite colored bishop
end games are just so disgusting uh that
sometimes being up two pawns even
connected is a draw uh it's that
unfortunate so we have a we have a few
individuals already making it to the
round of thirty two uh not here
he
uh picks up a win in three it's the
shortest way to win a match of best of
four maxima sheila grav had a smooth day
at the office uh with the exception of
one move in game three it seems like and
raunak sedwani already has knocked out
vessel into pollock i feel like today is
a very fast day
uh yeah i don't know how yes uh how fast
some of these matchups ended yesterday
but three out of our five matchups are
done in three games
you know it's
interesting because you would never
expect the match to be done so quickly
because everyone is
such a strong player in this field but
that's what happens in the opening round
we get the youth versus the veteran the
the young players they want today nuri
back and raunak upset the players who
have competed for world championships so
credit to them they worked very hard on
their game and then maxine for sure he
was the heavy favorite in his matchup
but two games two matches remain levy
and zhu and jun will have a chance to
bounce back what the white piece is and
pablo pogritov he gets the white pieces
and he has a one point lead so
vichy he's needed to come up with a win
on demand
yep uh we will see those two matches
potentially come to a conclusion in the
fourth rapid game or we will see epic
comebacks and then a bidding for an
armageddon we'll be back in about five
minutes don't go anywhere
[Music]
so
welcome back everyone to thechess.com
global championship it's our second day
of broadcasts and we are having the
spotlight on the round of 64 knockout
yesterday we had a super exciting day of
games and today as well we have all the
matchups uh coming to you from group f
which features
four world champions a world
championship challenger and we have a
bonus matchup for you
in group h now if you're just getting
here we'll run you up to speed like seem
did win that match up lexington the
frenchman uh defeated eduardo to rezaga
convincingly in three games but two
other matchups also were decided in
three rounds and that was ramik sedwani
the youngster of india
defeating vessel and tapala former world
champion as well as nojirek abdul
satorov taking down boris gelfand we've
got two matchups remaining with the
scores of 2-1 that fourth and final
rapid game will determine whether we are
done for this part of today's long
broadcast or whether we have an
armageddon uh that
those matchups one is perhaps the
understandable one anishigiri with the
two one lead he is the rating favorite
of the group it seems but
robert pavel punkarata is up 2-1 versus
vashawnathan anand and he just saved a
really tough end game uh we're gonna
show you the bracket here in a second
but uh that that matchup looks super
exciting uh and we will get to it and
this is just a preview of what will
happen should vishy or pavel advance
they will face nausea back
and the winner of the master between ju
and jun and the niche gary will face
ronak sedwani
both of those super exciting but robert
i was just going to the last thing i was
going to say was i think i would you
know not want to go up against snoji
breck i'm just
okay just avoid that pairing i think
that would be nice
you know i have nerdy beck winning this
group i have him moving on no matter who
he faces i had vishy winning his matchup
i think 91 of people had that same
result so i there will not be a perfect
bracket uh prediction if pop punk rots
off can in fact win this uh match up
against vichy but to your point levy
nordic
is my favorite in this group not because
i prefer one human being over another
but i think the way he's been playing in
recent months winning the olympiad being
the world rapid champion he seems
borderline unstoppable so uh yeah in his
final uh
sorry in vichy's final game against
pankaratov we'll see if vichy can be his
challenger or if uh punk rotzoff will
surprise the masses and move on yeah i
think uh they have just begun their game
that that is definitely major upset
watch uh i think
joon jun has to win with
is it with what is she playing white in
that game
she is white yeah so so she has a little
bit of a more comfortable situation
vichy doesn't so vishy has to win with
black he has to win on demand with the
black pieces
did he play an o'kelly sicilian
he did play a6 on move two and what else
can you play to win as black when you
need that result and no other i mean you
could play offbeat sicilians you could
play a pierce a modern but i don't think
that's vishy's style no no i mean those
two are
very comfortable for white this is just
going to be a very very
kind of a ageless setup battle a maraxi
and vichy's playing it like a hedgehog
style
um with b6 a6 d6 e6
we'll see i mean it's a tough spot when
you're when you're upon kratov you've
played super well but this is probably
the most nerve-wracking game for you
because you're right there you can taste
the round of 32 you can you can taste
defeating vichy which is probably going
to ruin everyone's bracket like if
there's someone out there that predicted
hanson would beat liam and pancrate
would beat vichy
i mean more power to you you should just
get the 100k right now so
there's definitely one person in chat
who's like oh is that
legally binding do i win it now
yeah like levy said i'm gonna get a
hundred thousand dollars where's my
money
yeah no uh that it would be very
impressive though and vishy
i was actually about to say that
thematically sometimes you play g4
because you have this pawn f3 but that
changed the evaluation levy and now if
the move d5 happens you have this
eyesore at the end of the diagonal f3 so
that seems to be a mistake practically
speaking more than anything why play g4
when all you need is a draw i don't know
that's completely insane i i was gonna
say i mean i i thought he was just gonna
play bishop e2 short castle b3 rook fd1
pre-move
like
just finish it but g4 is is crazy to me
i remember when i was really young
someone told me that the way to beat the
hedgehog was to attack it on the king
side and i played g4 h4 and then i like
lost in like 20 moves uh i had no idea
what i was doing this also strikes me as
a little bit peculiar because it feels
so
are you
are you seeing that move
what
is that a mouse slip no he seems what
what robert do you and i not understand
chess
can we just go back
two moves here i mean black is much
better we see the eval but we don't even
need the eval what is he doing what
have you ever seen this before
you mean you don't usually play g4 and
then followed up with king d1 that's not
what you're i mean i i understood like
king d1 must have been to go king c2
king b1 and castle by hand but
robert respectfully what the
what it what is this
black is spoiled for choice here you can
play b5 there's a king on c2 let's open
up this position and you want to play d5
okay so vici's vishy's moves are obvious
i
i can't comprehend this i think i think
he's doing it for the fans pancroat
wants the fans to enjoy an armageddon
game i don't robert he just he just sat
there and shook his head what's he
shaking his head he's the one who played
the moves
he did it to himself vichy just
developed his pieces it's not like fishy
started a crazy attack pancroat of just
out of nowhere when g4 king d1 king c2
king b1
what
[Music]
i don't understand now there's two pawns
under attack
robert i i this feels like black mirror
like why are neither of them reacting
[Laughter]
what does he do he's losing all his puns
i'm not laughing at the players but it's
truly i i could not have predicted a
single move in this game from white's
perspective
what is happening is this the weirdest
like top gm game you've ever seen i'm so
confused
yeah especially when you're up 2-1
against vichy clearly he's been playing
really well and maybe he got nervous
i don't understand what's happening here
oh my goodness
i am so confused
which pawn do you take
yeah this is the only thing that could
go wrong vichy just does not expect to
get such a position from the first year
i i mean taking on g4 looks very good
but i guess rook g1 you just need to
kind of
make sure you don't get checkmated
yeah that's true i'm not really scared
of getting checkmate because it's not
like white white spin how many turrets
king d1 king c2 king b1 it's not like
white has a leading development either i
hey
there's no words yeah this is this is
very shocking having said that it is
still a game and like i just said vishy
is thinking and he's giving respect to
the position because as completely
ludicrous as this looks he still
needs to
uh
take a pawn and do it the right way and
survive okay um
but yeah i'm so perplexed because i feel
like if janja ponchi was black he would
be sitting there like
you know like
i just i'm so i'm this is very very
confusing
it's like the game that he had against
ferruga where like frigid gave him all
the material and he just took took took
and yep
crushed the guy so let's make the move
knight takes g4 let's see what happens
yep the eval bar says minus two points
same eval knight takes c4 okay knight
t64 is actually incorrect so taking the
pawn that opens up your king is the
right decision taking the pawn that
opens up your opponent's king
potentially is the wrong one and i guess
that when you get a position like this
levy white has this impressive uh three
pawns on the fourth rank the c4 pawn may
be a target later in the game the d6
pawn may as well so
it makes perfect sense what taking on g4
is better but it's also riskier in some
ways yeah uh
taking on g4 definitely a little bit
riskier opening up that g file looks a
little bit scary but i think if there's
a guy that's gonna
kind of calculate that and
decide that it's a risk worth worth
taking it's it's vishy
admittedly he
he was in a very nice position last game
and he he had a little bit of a tilting
moment toward the end so anything is
possible but
such as
such as chess right like knight c4 does
look logical for black you could
convince yourself it's the right way to
go and vishi is taking a lot of time
here he will probably spend about 25 to
30 percent of his total time on this
decision because it's a huge one uh but
if he convinces himself that knight g4
is the best move
then um oh looks like he just went for
his mouse and a knight g4 on the board
he said you know what screw this i want
to play armageddon
right and when you're a five-time world
chess champion you don't really need
confidence from anybody else but i think
what he did there is instructive for
everybody watching including me like i
watched that moment i looked at his face
his reactions he was very calm and as
you were saying levy he was playing the
position he understands that pancratov
has just gone like completely astray
here but he said look i'm not gonna
think about that i'm just gonna find the
best move he sat spent almost three
minutes and found the best move even if
there is something to worry about on the
g file so i think vichy he's been a
class act his entire career and i don't
just mean that in terms of him being a
great person also the way he plays the
game uh this is a good moment and if he
does in fact convert this advantage
pancroat will be kicking himself for
maybe years to come yeah this is it's
going to be so so so wild but yeah pavel
is uh
i think he's also showing more emotion
than he has in any of the other games
like he he's shaking his head he's you
know his eyes are getting wider and i
i'm i honestly am just so confused
because
he kind of did it all himself like he
did it was not asked for whatsoever
maybe
uh there was some other type of move
order in the morocci where g4 is is a
plan or king d1 is a plan like i
wouldn't doubt it these guys don't just
play complete nonsense right like there
might be a certain type of setup where
kingdom one kingston is a thing robert i
swear to you i have never seen it in my
life so if you have you gotta tell me
but i've never seen this whole plan that
he played ever
i've seen king walks before even in
early stages of games but it made no
sense g4 and king d1 like in conjunction
with one another it was just
just befuddling i i just can't really
grasp what he was thinking i don't think
he understands what he was thinking he's
sitting there look at him right he's
upset with himself because he's like all
i need to do is draw the game and i
chose the most aggressive possible path
that is backfiring completely so vishy
is in great shape maybe we could take
this time to go to the other game
between the other match i should say
between anishigiri and jim won jun
because zhu and jun needs to win this
game with the white pieces and she chose
this opening that it seemed like
in 2020 let me everybody was playing
this opening and then thankfully they
all stopped
yes
this is the
ultra passive line against the bishop f4
queen's gambit declined where it looks
like white should just be completely
winning visually like it just if you
look at this position at really any
level even even at
my level i look at this i'm like how
does black survive this black is just in
time black basically has one move at
every juncture to constantly trade
things and make a draw and anish knows
that he's
he's seen this a million times
uh and
i i don't know if she's gonna be able to
reinvent the wheel here i really don't
and uh i'm a little bit surprised she
chose this approach i mean maybe the
catalan is not in her repertoire i don't
know julian june's repertoire that well
but you know you could go try to go for
a catalan the problem is that robert a
d4 c4 knight f3 knight c3 black has a
lot of just
super solid lines that you don't need to
do anything in and uh well and each
chose one and you know he's gonna have
to defend this position but i i think he
should be all right
i think the biggest problem that juan
june was facing is that she's against
aneesh giri who is one of if not the
most prepared player on the planet right
he is renowned for his opening theory
and so what do you choose when you just
lost game three in a kind of a
surprising fashion our position crumbled
in no time and then you have to win and
you're like all right anish one of the
best players in the world he's super
well prepared what do you choose he
plays the catalan himself so i'm not
saying that i would have gone for this
but i
i guess i'm saying i don't know what i
would have gone for there's no real
great option that sticks out
yeah there absolutely isn't it sometimes
really feels like a black wants to make
a draw as sam shanklin said to me he was
like if if i want to make a draw in some
opening like i have that in my toolbox
and this is one opening where
the ship forest is kind of it's kind of
neutralized but i think she did
she played bishop f4 in the other game
as well but he played knight bd7 so he
didn't play a traditional qgd but i
definitely think that between the two
games we should definitely focus on the
vishi one because this one's going to
take
some time uh it's going to be a very
very slow developing process but that
game could be over 10 moves 15 moves
yeah here we are we see the oh gosh
i wasn't joking man i was not
exaggerating because pankarativ is not
going to want to sit around and i mean
he's just completely lost he's
completely gone off the rails
um
it's amazing that f takes g6 was a move
that went from like minus three to minus
six because
wait can you
can you take and there's running no
because it's a gh7 so of course you
can't take so
fg i guess
and just the open f file is that amazing
for you
i i think so okay he does it this way
i'm actually shocked like fg was oh my
god
um this is what you call desperation
this is not some uh wizardry this is not
mikhail tal playing uh some brilliant
sacrifice this is just like i'm dead
lost so let me
play hope chess
yeah yeah wow i
this has been such a weird game
do you agree i just feel like
that first game was wizardry level of
defense the second game was a convincing
win with white then it was like a clutch
end game escape
what the hell is this game like i don't
know what the storyline here is
g4 king d1 all sorts of crazy stuff and
he has 11 minutes on the clock he's just
blitzing all his moves and
i guess he's just ready to go to
armageddon
i don't have words
for what has happened in this game
because
pablo punkaratov is an exceptional chess
player
the level he's played in this game is
surprisingly low it i mean look at him
right the guy is just upset and vici's
bored but she's like all right i'm
appeased i can win this in my sleep and
pancrato is sitting there like
i mean what in the world have i done
yeah vishy vishy showed a little bit of
emotion when he kind of like opened his
mouth last game and sort of like
probably audibly exhaled after not being
able to win that end game yeah vishi
just kind of has this look always like
why am i here
why did i agree to this
nbl looks mad but the good for mvl he's
done with his games today and probably
went out and got like a
you know a nice quest home for lunch oh
my goodness bishop d7 there's eval bar
is coming up from from the dead here
which is always getting me a bit scared
i think we can understand why somehow
this position is not just completely
winning
oh my goodness b3
oh do you want queen d2 or something to
defend
he just wants queen d2 and white can't
really move but oh my god
eval bar giving me a heart attack here
yeah i can see the depth going up you
know lev and i don't have the moves that
should be played but we i do have the
eval bar available and it's go as the
depth goes up it shows how strong that
move was and b3 is a move that i think
99 people would not even consider
because the king is under attack bishop
takes g6 with a threat so people often
defend directly they'd make a move like
king h7 or something just to defend the
pawn but that's a brilliant move because
queen d2 can happen and then even queen
h6 and you're defending uh your king
side bringing the queen back around
b3 is awesome it's an amazing move
because actually if if not for b3 like
if white's pawn had been on the b3
square there b2 was on b3 um
yeah you got some seriously nice looking
sacrifices bishop g6 you got queen e4 i
mean it's all losing but
we have to look for something we can't
just sit here and go okay it's over you
know it's it's really not
there's still possibility to blunder
uh
and and i think
we're very prone to kind of throwing out
games that especially when the evil bar
is on
is anything but over you know you give
this position to uh
to a student to take over they might
lose this with black in three or four
moves because
it's actually not so not as easy as they
thought to defend the against white's
attack rightly let's say you make with a
queen c5 very logical move on trade
queens eval bar already goes winning for
white right that's a normal looking move
queen to c5 but after queen e4 rook
takes g6 you're probably just gonna
check me so that's insane wow yeah nice
catch
and that's what happens right in these
positions oh it's my opponent sacked the
piece out of desperation's nothing and i
actually am guilty of stating that
myself but then you have to find movies
like b3 and rook e1 played by
giving up this pawn with check to go for
the attack
drama era arrows better this fish one e7
still bishop g6 so you give up this pawn
with check and
i i don't believe in it nero is the evil
bar but good try five punk roto yeah
definitely is a great try absolutely i
mean queen e4 is like a quiet move
setting up rook takes g6 and then it
just completely wins so it's very
important for vichy to be to be punctual
with this counter play what a move by
the way rookie one my god what a move
it's a scary move watch victory play
some like bishop g5 because the rook on
e1 is loose or something like that yeah
bishop g5 is looks uh looks awesome and
threatens mate
yeah this pawn a2 is threatened with
macy then you have to spend some time
taking on b3 but even if a takes b3 is
played there's rook on e1 that's the
problematic piece so the bishop one g5
cuts off the circulation of white's
attack so i like that rookie eight to
follow there's probably many other moves
that should do the trick but vishy
spending his time wisely and by the way
levy it appears that if punk rotten wins
this match there's still five perfect
brackets remaining
that's so wild five out of ten thousand
well listen you gotta blame the players
for showing up and ruining everything
right
uh hey
i i will we redraw if after like uh the
first uh few days or maybe after the
first round of 64. can we adjust that or
is that just from the beginning because
i just feel like it's a little bit of a
letdown you know it's only three rounds
and we don't have any more bracket
competitions
that just feels a little sad
start a new one i guess just uh start
doing like those prop bets like in
all these uh other sports right just
like oh who is going to win the first
game with black in the round of 32. now
listen imagine on on draftkings or
something we we had some sort of like
chess and you know you can draft like
hicaro or you can draft nepo it costs
more points can you rather be sick it
would be like
he did play bishop g5 what a savage
yeah
over under number of moves in a match i
mean there's so many different prop bets
that can be uh had in chess yes only
problem is
yeah stuff like that is tricky right
because like uh move move count or
whatever i mean theoretically a guy
could bet on himself to lose and then
go and make that happen but
uh in individual sports i suppose it's
different in team sports but
anyway it takes b3 played uh we will
keep our business ideas to ourselves for
now
and uh yeah what is the plan here for
vichy like rook
i was gonna say like rook b8 okay just
queen bee 2 a.m
the way he's playing this game is just
fantastic okay pancrasa made his life
easier in some ways but
since that moment it's just been
very precise not perfect no chess player
is perfect but it's minus five he's up a
piece he's coordinating his pieces
rook's coming to e8 king is feeling
safer and safer by the turn bishop f5 is
already a big threat because this queen
on d4 is loose and the bishop's pin yeah
nicely done by bishi oh that's true and
at the end of the day black might have
something like bishop h6 bishop g7 you
have to be a little careful but
you can always just go back rook 88 to
trade some material um
yeah this this one i'm not gonna say
anything because the last time that i
spoke literally on that same second
vishi made a mistake
and i i misspoke actually wasn't trying
to say that he had won the game i was
saying he's on his way
so we'll see if fushi can can uh put it
all together how is uh jiu and jun doing
in her
quest to beat
the brick wall that is the queen's game
but declined
has she made progress
no no in fact quite the opposite
actually
this good night on c4
questionable pawn on h4 right it's like
uh
the things i'm noticing c5 clogged up
beep file open pressure on the b4 pawn
yeah levy this is
you can hardly fault zhu and jun because
beating anishikiri
is really difficult um but
yeah this is not going her way
no it's tough i mean to to to beat a
niche
you gotta you gotta get him deep into
theoretical waters and kind of
uh throw like a little you know you
gotta throw a little sprinkle on
something when you when you play
something i think some of these like
really forced draw lines with black they
they they just have way too much in
their toolbox and
she also just kind of has a random bond
on h4 because i guess she was
hoping that you know that would turn
into something but if white's b4 porn
trades for black c6 pawn it's it's it's
time to
you know kind of wrap it up i i think um
yeah i think probably the game to watch
is definitely the vichy game
no disrespect whatsoever but
this one's tough
yeah just clog c file and open a file
that black controls there's nothing to
threaten the c61 is usually what you go
after but you're not getting your piece
around let's go back to the vishi game
with pankaratov we will keep an eye on
this one but the other game is
definitely a bit more exciting so yeah i
i do just want to say nobody looks happy
it's crazy like not a single one of the
players looks happy at all
it's tough
no anish
like should be the happiest of the four
of them uh but it's been a struggle and
you don't take any player for granted
and uh for vichy right now he's down to
three and a half minutes so with the
material being too
is it just one pawn it's just one pawn
never mind i was like two pawns for a
piece and a potential attack but there's
only one pawn for the piece
yeah it's only a pawn and
it doesn't even really like you don't
even feel the pawns here you you look at
the black pawns on f7 and g6 protecting
the king but other than that
it's
they ain't nothing ain't nothing going
here you get the queens off
but if there's no attack
okay but vichy has three minutes and
that is like making me concerned a
little bit
yeah i'm worried about the internet
gambit but vishy usually has stable
connection and then i'm just a little
concerned because the king is open rook
g2 can happen sacrifices on g6
so vishy trying to be perfect here and
sometimes perfect is the enemy of the
good where you're spending way too much
time trying to uh
find the best computer line every time
yeah for sure i i was gonna say i i feel
like vichy's at the point in life where
he shouldn't be paying for internet they
should be paying him to represent the
internet company
uh i mean i think it's kind of
ridiculous if you're if you're fishy and
you're still paying for stuff like that
you know you got to get the best of the
best
uh yeah he's
he's going to make a few more moves he
still has to be careful like there's
still various bishop takes g6 things
lurking
in fact a move ago bishop takes g6 look
pretty scary
yeah i guess the plan was
what was the plan
you can't take right because then the
queen just takes and you get h5
you get checkmate over here
so i get rookie two
or bishop f7 no
seven king h8 i guess
can you take oh you can take yeah my
king's gonna run away we he learned a
lesson from pankaratov you know the king
can
yeah anything you can do i can do better
right
wow
okay i think fishy has a minute and 45
though i don't like this
like yeah queen d4 vici is just very
tentative it feels like i am there we go
and
can you wait now can you take because
after queen takes there's bishop g7 yeah
i i don't know what the idea there was i
mean i think i think the idea was i'm
done
well he he kind of tilted here because
he actually had a chance when vishy's
down to a minute and 40 seconds and
there's the you know the potential of an
attack even if it's not going to work
out just immediately giving vishy
obvious moves is not the way to go
i i feel like
i feel like pavil and and his current
facial expression is basically a
microcosm of what chelsea feels like
he just it's just pain and and vishy's
just sort of like reading a book or
studying you know rocks or something
like he's
got a magnifying glass and he's like
studying leaves that he collected or
something you know he he just always
kind of has like a
a nice kind of calm demeanor um yeah
pivo looks distraught and it's crazy
because he played so well for three
games and
you know what
i keep forgetting levy is that there's
going to be another game for pablo i'm
looking at him as if he just lost the
most important game of his life and
maybe that's true
but he gets another game after this yep
and that's it
resignation if queen takes f5 queen
takes g1 with check then this queen is
picked up so vishwanathan anand the
five-time world chess champion wins with
black he needed to get this one
and they're going to armageddon they are
going to armageddon and
that was one of the most peculiar games
i've ever been a part of commentating on
i don't understand what happened i don't
understand what happened between games
three and four that caused such a thing
i'm just confused man
yeah i
there really is no explanation and i
think
uh pav will be the first person to say
like what was i doing i was playing the
good match i was up a point i was
holding with black i won my game with
white and then to play g4 king d1 and
all this stuff in a sicilian especially
when you play the moroxy bind you just
get the bind you don't open the position
up for your opponent
yeah super strange super super strange
uh a very odd match also for vichy to be
involved in vishy uh is now gonna just
go catch a breather now there is a
bidding process right for the armageddon
we should remind the viewers so uh we do
have obviously one more game here joe
and tune has to win to force the
armageddon it's not looking likely it
looks like a niche will win
an advance here in group f but the other
two players remaining will now start a
bidding process now robert
is it like ebay where you have uh bid
this but that or do they just submit the
amount of minutes they would be willing
to start with once and the lower bid
wins they do that so
the team is working hard behind the
scenes communicating with the players
there is no increment in armageddon
that's easy to forget when you play four
games with a two second increment so
they're talking the players who
separately submit their bid and
yesterday for example in the first
matchup that went to armageddon ralph
momento bid 12 minutes nielsen bit 11.
so nihil got 11 minutes with the black
pieces and draw odds whereas ralph had
white with 15 minutes but he needed to
win that game
understood can they can they bet seconds
like 30 seconds they certainly can okay
i do they know that
uh they should i'm pretty sure it's
communicated to them but i
i i'm gonna ask because i wasn't
gonna go for the strategic 1045 you know
why
was it hansen yesterday who after
winning with three seconds on the clock
was on stream and then said uh
he didn't know there was increment he
didn't know there was no increment i'm
pretty sure that's what he said
which is crazy that's completely on the
players it's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah hansen also has played in
armageddon before i think and against
fedor maybe where he also didn't know
there was increments so it's like a
recurring theme
yeah uh anish has won the b pawn by the
way absolutely best case scenario here
white makes uh draw
uh white is no longer eligible to win
this game anish has netherlands internet
it's probably the best in the world i've
seen it at one ping
it he he's going to be all right i'm
sure their fiber optic cables are really
solid and
anish will be moving on and he is going
to await um
no he already has an opponent he will be
taking on roundok sedwani in group f
round of 32.
right so i mean he's still concentrated
because he knows that if he doesn't
look all across the board there's a rook
g3 checkman in one he's not going to get
checkmated there might just be f5 after
rook g3 because the rook on c4 is lewis
things of that nature but he could put a
simple g6 i don't think he needs to take
any risk whatsoever you can't
mate with just this rook and queen over
on the king's side it's not enough
material yeah it's not enough material
and uh
by the way if geary makes it through to
toronto that would be legendary because
he will most likely have to go through
raunak
and noid your back
i mean i'm assuming you know node gets
through vichy that's what you predicted
but
um i decided to kind of uh be a devil's
advocate and i and i said that
experience was going to prevail over
youth in that matchup but i i'm i'm
really not 100 certain
i feel like if it was over the board
i think vichy definitely has some sort
of edge but online it really seems like
the young guys are just are just
extremely sharp
they certainly are and by the way i i
did five yeah i did it yeah five looks
very good the queen can then slide over
to the king side to help out i i did ask
the team and they quickly gave me the
answer uh for the bids yesterday and it
two players bit 11 minutes and 59
seconds carrillo leksenko and liquing
liam
did so and they their opponents bit 12
minutes so they did one second under
their opponent
[Music]
wow
five heads genius that's like the price
is right you know
[Laughter]
oh that's really really smart wait a
second but both alex cinco and the quang
liam lost so maybe their bids while
they got the color of their choice it
didn't work out for them
but nihal nihal did win right with less
time but he bit 11 minutes on the dot
you know he
right he kept he kept it
uh nice round numbers
right right right that was crazy by the
way i mean to win with black not even to
you know make the draw with like well
armageddon draw is very tough result i
mean it's
um
generally as a winner and a loser i
think armageddon the level of play also
plummets i think that's been studied uh
we will we go to a break before the
armageddon
or are they just gonna like roll
directly into it yeah we'll get a break
before that because the players need to
get set up and all that stuff so uh by
the way does this position look like
minus 4.6 to you it's amazing these
neural net engines that you're like okay
black is better in the old days kev
blanco would win this with his eyes
closed and he'd demonstrate great
technique now it's like minus 4.7
i think that's because of the line c5
yeah okay well actually that was not
well oh no and and i had queen h6 i was
thinking rook d4 h5 rook h4 or something
like but there might even be mate like
queen b1 rook d1
oh look at that it's happening
oh there's also queen b1 rook h4 if you
play h5 yeah so this is yeah
so now the
queen and rook team up and the kings
game made it it really did not look like
a position that was
so overwhelmingly advantageous for geary
and
it makes perfect sense now that i've
seen
what's
happened so this looks pretty natural
so
i don't know are we allowed to disclose
to the public what people have bet what
pancratov and vishy
i don't know if that's actually we only
have pancrato we don't have vicious bid
yet so yeah we don't we don't have the
vishy bid
but but these bids are oh that's i guess
we don't have issues but we don't want
to say anything because it's all done
just to one person who relays it to us
so oh it's very secret
yeah we don't want to uh tell the
broadcast the the bet and then one guy
hasn't submitted yeah that seems like it
would be tampering
and you know well that would also
require either vision to be watching the
stream which he's definitely not doing
or somebody to actually know vishy you
know a chat they'll pretend like they
know people it's like yeah she's my guy
um
i you know i doubt anybody here uh maybe
there are some people who happen to know
this you personally by the way anisha
only needs a draw so he's probably not
even going to win this game he's just
going to make a draw there's there's
actually some pretty hilarious ways to
lose like if white tries to chase the
king out and it gets to f6 and it's mate
for white but yeah anisha's not going to
blunder that like for example you could
accidentally allow like queenie
i don't know queenie 2 king g5 queen g2
and then there's even there's even queen
b2 at the end so
i'm just looking for
ways to lose
but uh i think that's it queenie one
should be three times yup anish geary
shaking his head because he knows he's
gonna get trolled for making a draw in a
winning position but he does advance
to the round of 32.
you know all jokes aside he does seem
very stressed right like i think that he
cares a ton about this event there is a
huge monetary prize at stake first place
is 200 000
and he knows that if he plays his best
he can make the top eight and go to the
live finals in toronto and have a shot
at a huge payday and just a global
championship title so i feel like he's
feeling the weight of this event where
he know and i i told everybody you know
we he and i spoke and he said that he
didn't even look at his brackets he may
now know that he's gonna play ranuk next
but he did not know when we spoke in
fact he got mad at me for even talking
about the bracket when we were messaging
so wow i i i didn't know that anish
could get mad i had absolutely no idea
um
it was mad in like a very gentle way you
know okay a joking way i understand well
congratulations to anish giri he is our
fourth qualifier into the round of 32
today uh and he has now secured an extra
5000 bucks for 17 to 32nd place uh there
it is up it was up on your screen now
you got i got two big bozos here on
camera mode uh on your screen we're
gonna take a very short break and we are
going to return for our final chess game
of this broadcast obviously the cgc is
extremely long we have a lot of
different matchups a lot of commentary
teams uh and we will return and when we
do return we will know who's playing
white who's playing black in the
armageddon matchup between vichy anand
and final contradict to determine who is
the final qualifiers the round of 32 in
group
[Music]
so
open to anyone
all around the world
the chess.com global championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
and hey
have we mentioned there's also a million
dollars at stake the total pot is a
million dollars no that is not a typo
the prizes are unbelievably generous
we began with thousands of players
now only dozens remain
there it is oh my god
this is crazy eric hanson moves on to
the round of 32 in armageddon fashion
the cgc knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are
things are about to get very
very real
what what maybe i just literally
what
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends
it's the cgc round of 64.
who will take the next step to toronto
welcome back everyone to the chess.com
global championship today is the second
day of action here in the knockouts
round of 64 and we are finishing our
morning coverage with an armageddon so
this is a very interesting type of
format some of you may have heard of
this before in armageddon uh the person
who has less time
plays black but has draw odds so if the
game ends in a draw
they actually win the game now generally
that's either five minutes to white four
minutes to black or something along
those lines but we have a bidding system
robert and would you like to fill in the
viewers
uh what we just got told during the
break yeah i'm still typing to the team
behind the scenes because
vichyanan bid seven minutes so he will
have the black pieces with seven minutes
pablo punkaratov will have 15 minutes
with white and powell needs to win so i
was confirming a few things that vichy
knew that there was no increment that he
knew that the base time was 15 minutes
the team actually asked him those
specific questions seven minutes black
versus 15 white this she said correct
repeated it uh
vocally as well so i'm shocked but vichy
must have that much confidence in his
ability to draw with black and his
bullet skills
yeah that's completely nuts
we were both shocked at this bet uh well
bet i suppose uh offer bid
the lowest bid thus far has been 11
minutes right and we've only had a few i
mean the cgc knockouts have just begun
vishy
just made the lowest bet set he is going
to have
less than half of the time
that's
ludicrous and it's not like he gets
armageddon 40 moves 60 moves that that
is one of the formats of armageddon that
has happened before after 60 moves you
get an extra bonus second if the game
goes that long that's crazy
that is a savage wager
and pancrasa bid 14 and a half minutes
so you know he wanted the white pieces
he only was going to give up 30 seconds
on his clock and so i am i mean vishy
could have bid 14 minutes and 29 seconds
that he still would have had blackened
rods but you of course don't know what
your opponent's bit is seven minutes
is
what
seven minutes that feels like a type o
he just you know said the wrong number
but no she's that confident
yeah uh
and we were sort of concerned players
would think that maybe it's a 10-minute
armageddon and
therefore they would
they would maybe bet nine minutes or
seven minutes or something no they are
well aware it is 15 minutes
well aware
uh it is a full-on rapid game uh and
this is basically like if vichy was
playing in the world rapid championship
and literally showed up seven minutes
late eight minutes late so we're about
to get going we're about to have the
game in a minute or two or right now
actually
i just i'm still in disbelief
seven minutes the bid for vichy uh pablo
he must be really really happy uh to get
this time advantage but what's he gonna
do right we just saw him play with the
white pieces and he went i mean he went
berserk right there's
no other way of framing it the guy
played one of the worst games of his
life perhaps
yeah we it chess is a world where we
really don't say things like so harshly
about players in our commentary like in
basketball they're like yeah he played
he had a horrible game i that yeah like
that was just not good but he's about to
start a game with eight more minutes in
his opponent all right vichy's going
e4 e5 old school he's like i can
equalize with black no problem and we
just don't need to do that we just saw
anish literally do exactly that versus
joe and jun um robert how about how are
you feeling about like an evan's gambit
i know it's not on the board but you
know guys got seven minutes no increment
you might as well just play some crazy
gambit lines but now we're seeing uh oh
okay that's a forcing line
d5
yep now we're going to get
you know what's the problem
wait wait robert what is bishop e2 isn't
it bishop b5 some sort of sideline yeah
bishop e2 has like become also a trendy
variation as well like okay it's in the
engine age where you don't get any
advantage with white you try all these
little things uh but the problem with
playing vichy is that not only has he
been around for like decades at the
highest level he's still at the highest
level we saw him go back over the board
everyone's like oh he's not playing
anymore he's retired he goes on and
beats maxine and all these other top
guys so he's still working on his chest
good luck finding an opening advantage
but i think the best thing and maybe
you'll disagree but maybe you you will
back me up here is i think probably
needs to keep pieces on the board you
can't trade you can't make fishy's
decisions easy and f6 is coming soon so
i feel like vichy's next few
moves these little plans are actually
kind of obvious
yes exactly uh knight a4 is not really a
move that intends to keep many pieces on
the board but it's definitely looking
for at least one exchange but you're
right here comes f6 and
this is going to get very forcing very
quickly
and i think the pressure is actually on
pavel because he has eight more minutes
than his opponent eight he has more than
fifty percent of the start time
the problem is vichy is coming from an
elite class of players pogba is an
absolutely incredible player as well but
like we saw in the anish game if they
want to equalize with black they will do
it it's like breathing for them it's
that simple
but the problem is vichy has six moves
six minutes with no bonus time at all
so
we might see a dirty flag that is
actually a legitimate option here for
pavilion
yes yesterday we saw a couple players
attempting the dirty flag ralph
momentoff could not make it working as
neal sarah and then
he played it out down two queens and got
checkmated against eric hanson but the
weight vicious played thus far he spent
a minute um for 12 moves but he i think
feels very comfortable with his position
i think he's done the early stage of the
game quite well but if he keeps spending
like eight to 12 seconds per move that's
when i'm gonna get really worried on his
behalf
yes exactly and as we can see here okay
uh we're gonna probably see de5 but
knight e5 is not unreasonable either
with the intention of f3 f4 i i actually
really like bible's position and i
believe he's even spent less time than
vishy despite having more of it to begin
with
great choice though by vichy to retreat
tonight he did not want to allow this
pawn to e5 because if we split the board
in half white already has an extra pawn
on the king side and that's where the
kings are so if you give white a second
pawn there and then allow the f pawn to
roam that would have been very
problematic for the black king so i
really love knight to d6 then i can come
to f5 or maybe even c4 at some point so
vichy
obviously world class but a great
decision there
yeah i now i to me the move f2 to f4
looks awesome but of course it comes
with the drawback of giving up some
light squares but who knows maybe then
king h1 and g4 f5 by white is an idea
i can get behind that for sure like just
start throwing pawns at the board
maybe just scare your opponent and pavel
was playing more quickly than vishy now
he's slowed down because the last thing
he can afford is a series of trades that
make the position clearly equal it's not
about the evaluation bar that's not what
pavo really cares about it's the
complexity of the position
yes exactly let's not forget
five thousand dollars is on the line
as well as a potential
next step qualification right so
yes in in in some cases you can argue
that flagging someone in a drawn rook
end game is
not great
on the other hand when it's such high
stakes it just becomes part of the game
unfortunately there is
you know there's no there's no other way
to slice it like we have to find a way
to break ties uh between players of this
caliber a draw is by far the most likely
result in the game draws will not take
us to any next stage he does play f4
which is
uh both concerning and uh rewarding for
me because it's very concerning he
played the move i suggested
uh but maybe he he liked it but now vish
is going to put the bishop on e4 right
and
it's going to be a little tough here to
make progress
i mean just great control of the light
squares for vichy and he made that last
move in about 11 12 seconds so he's
keeping a good pace it's good enough for
now
i'm just still so nervous when you're
down this much time but i feel like
there's much more clarity right we know
what we're going for white's going for
some uh
improvements on the king side black is
now taking control of squares that white
has just
handed over to him so i still feel like
from a strategic standpoint if she knows
what's going on but five and a half
minutes not that much time
no not that much time but it's it's no
longer a 2x time advantage i mean it's
it's it's right there on the verge right
uh and
paival has spent four minutes now
roughly
about three and a half minutes and vishy
has spent uh one and a half minutes so
at this pace they're both gonna get down
to
two to maybe two minutes at the same
time uh having said that yeah paiva's
you know he's he's playing he's playing
the the games one through three paiva
right now he is not playing like game
four bible you know there was game six
jordan there's game four private and
right now i like how he's playing but
vichy is about to
potentially flip everything here with
various you know defensive moves i like
queen e8 here by the way or
okay but i like the queen e8 just kind
of stabilizing
i'm totally with you there queen eight
looked pretty good knight to e7 ride the
knight to a5
is this pawn going to be captured no he
just he wants opposite bishops levy oh
he's so he's so clever down a pawn but
light squared bishop dark squad bishop
c6 queen d5 just make a draw
that is
i mean that's such a good decision
because i was wondering how am i going
to avoid losing a pawn he does not have
the pawn and the best players in the
world they do this all the time they
know when the material
material equality is not worth it it's
about the activity of the pieces so
giving up upon c4 just to very quickly
show you what that looks like at the end
of this c6 queen e5 as levy point out
we have a great bishop on e4 your extra
pawn is not going anywhere either on d4
and f4 so yeah this is looking like
great chances to hold for vichy plus as
we keep saying levy it becomes clearer
and clearer what black needs to
accomplish
yeah paival does not want that to happen
but now the problem is uh he's going to
have
some serious difficulties i i think
can't black take on e3 and play the move
c6 and just be absolutely chilling
yes
it just looks so good i mean
or that okay i'm kind of shocked he
didn't take on e3 but vichy's being
stubborn that's what he's doing he just
doesn't want to we have bishops he wants
a great move mm-hmm
now that actually was a missed
opportunity because
we keep talking about this you want
clarity you want the position uh to
become more obvious what to do now with
the bishop on the board is b3 about to
hit you at some point a3 is hanging for
the moment but these are things now you
have to consider that were not available
had he just captured this bishop on e3
we're getting dangerously close to very
very suspicious time territory like i
think when vishy's clock hits three
minutes that's when things are gonna if
there's this amount of pieces on the
board that's when things are gonna get
really dangerous for him
because
if paival does this the right way which
is not easy your heart's probably
pounding well i don't know pyvel just
looks cute cool as a cucumber but i'm
sure there's a there's a lot of stress
there everybody kind of handles it
differently so
uh but but vishy's catching up you know
it's okay that's
wow
g4 what a move love it the move you have
to play in a position like this when
your opponent's at four and a half
minutes so what is vichy's response
going to be now
i'm
levi the more i think about it that
knight takes e3 that's a huge missed
opportunity from vichy like i think that
would have solved many of his problems
these knights are superfluous knights
and they're fighting for the same
squares and this bishop on c1 maybe
later in the game will become active
even after removing f5 yeah and now we
might get queen g3 here and yup
h4h5 like
white's position is suddenly playing
itself this is not a good situation
vichy has run out of moves
that are kind of like easy moves to play
to improve your position it's about to
get really yeah he's gonna have to rely
on moves like this
mostly because of the time situation he
just has to play quick moves
what a weird place for that bishop of
the sibling is he going knight e4 now
the bishop can't be attacked that bishop
could be attacked he's just gonna get
trapped but the queen is nowhere to go
on the third ranked to attack and if you
play queen f3 there could be a knight d2
fork at some moment that's so ridiculous
maybe there's takes takes queen c3
knight f1 oh but then there's like rook
f4 at the end or something i mean it's
it's super super wild i mean if if i'm
gonna put you know a wager on
who between the two of them might
blunder uh a tactic in a time scramble
it's it's really tough to
to predict that vishy will do that right
but here it is i just mentioned three
minutes is on the clock for vichy
anything below three minutes nothing
good is gonna happen okay it's like
robert you and i are new yorkers nothing
good happens between two and three am
okay except maybe some parties but
it's uh
it's a ba bad time to uh
to to be out on the streets i mean it
but but here's the thing pankaratev has
to also
grasp the fact that the position is very
sharp will he continue to push forward
and how
yeah it's easy to blunder here from
easier to blend it for white than is for
black i think because um you know you go
for this mindset i need to win the game
you make a move like f5 then you drop
this upon e5 can't do that you do
something on the queen side not much
going on there so i feel like these
individual decisions are harder for
white to make and quincy to totally
reasonable move i'm like ignoring the
evaluation for the time being as long as
it doesn't really dip it's kind of all
the same
absolutely agreed with you um
yeah wow
what a
what a crazy bit if this pays off it's
actually kind of insane that he put the
bishop on c2 and it just can't be
removed
he was bishop he want knight d6 bishop
c4 at some point something like that
or knight takes e5 and then bishop c4
trading off the light square bishops is
huge for him and then look at this
knight on e4 good luck getting out of
there that's one of the reasons i was
worried about that f4 g4 plan but vichy
somehow has made this work and it's
fascinating it looks so intimidating to
play black here but white can't move
anything white relies too heavily on the
blockade in the center so maybe white
has to play knight d3 before making more
progress but that just seems like a bad
move it just seems like a step in the
wrong direction yeah i agree with you
also vishy has spent
about three and a half minutes you start
with seven just to remind everybody and
pancroat of us now spent eight minutes
so in terms of time consumption
pancreatitis doing the right thing he
started with so much extra time but you
know when you start feeling like you're
the one thinking a lot your opponent's
playing quickly you start trusting your
opponent or getting worried that they
have a better grasp of the position i
wonder if pancras is in that mindset he
looks fully concentrated levy but i get
the sense that he kind of is trusting
vichy and that can also add to your
nerves
absolutely and also realizing that you
actually don't have forward progress
it's a very frustrating feeling and to
mention uh not to mention that your your
time gap has gone from eight to three
minutes so i i did mention a while ago
that they're going to get to around two
minutes at the same time because of the
pace of the game wow that is a giant
decision by vichy i am shocked but
bishop c4 you think
where else is that bishop going i guess
there's like a queen c5 check at some
point but as bishop comes up to e3 this
is becoming a potential nightmare for
vichy if this pawn can get up to f5
oh boy
bishop e3 does he have
d4
the ship f2 and queen f2
yeah oh oh wow wow
okay i'm so tempted to play d4 bishop b5
with my bishop was hanging on b3 so i
can't get away with
that's very easy to blunder by the way
yeah those bishops before wow bishop d1
my god bishop d wants an excellent move
your opponent has 250 on the clock you
got to go bishop d1
is there bishop f1 here something like
that because the bishop on c1 is lost i
guess he's just solved in a different
way he clears the diagonal
yeah the insane thing is vishy has to
just play on instinct and the thing is
vichy is not like you know a 16 or 17
year old player like he he he's not
playing
moves in in in a millisecond like they
do in in hyper bullet or these insane
bullet matches like he's
mouse speed actually becomes a factor as
you get later and later in the arm again
and wow f5 this is unbelievable what an
armageddon game
four results are possible here
[Laughter]
you know vichy really did not have to
bid seven minutes that's gonna be the
talk no matter the result of this game
most people don't bid below 11. so a bit
seven minutes just felt maybe
unnecessary however he is handling
himself
quite nicely but these pawns are moving
that's bad news for the black king
yeah there there's footage of vichy on
youtube thinking for like a minute on
the fourth move of a blitz game and
still winning i i don't i don't know i
don't know why he does this to himself
but it like i said three minutes was
that cutoff point nothing is g good is
going to happen beyond that and the
worst part for him is the position is
getting ultra sharp and we are going to
see crazy evaluation swings
yes we will because f6 very natural
moves to try to pry open the king side
that might be a mistake he goes g5 here
and there the eva goes down a little bit
before vichy's just he's playing an
instant he has to he is not that afraid
but g6 oh my gosh oh that is a crazy
looking move all of the pawns looks
horrible to deal with
what's going to do oh no he's going to
lose his game i mean there's just no way
to survive with the king here
f6
yeah rook oh rook a7 they're going to be
bishop e3 at some point
yeah there might be there might be
bishop a3
that's nasty distracting the rook from
the seventh rank where it's defending
yeah that looks like desperation mode
yeah oh man it's just f7 yep f7 isn't
this mate
it looks like it
how do you stop checkmate
i don't yeah and i think vichy knows it
vishy knows it and pancrata looking
like he is in tip-top shape here to
deliver a final blow a couple of moves
and he will be the last person in group
f to make it to the round of 32. what a
battle
and what a stair punk razor has i mean
that guy's scaring me i'm not even his
opponent
yeah i mean just j just a very strange
turn of events these last few games yeah
vishy doesn't
i feel like vichy once again doesn't
exactly know where the resign button is
i think he looks like he's looking
around
yeah he's going to resign and you can
just tell by you know he's trying to
find it he's not used to it he doesn't
resign very often
yeah
i mean you you can sort of see his case
his hand is kind of kind of hovering and
uh yeah pancrotiv does a little head nod
what a what an attack by pancrato
honestly an excellent game here
wonderfully played
yeah it was definitely decided
before move one i mean seven minutes
levy we were trying to give him the
benefit that he has officially resigned
pavel pankaratov has spoiled all of your
brackets except for five of you out
there so you could thank him that you
don't have a chance at a hundred
thousand dollars
yeah what an absolutely amazing day at
the office for pavel pancratov who in
four of these five games
played like he had been you know the
favorite in in the matchup it was
he was just rock solid he was tricky he
was resourceful
and he's still shaking his head because
he's kind of unhappy with the way this
all transpired because
he was up 2-1 and the last game did not
have to go the way it did he was white
he didn't know exactly how to handle the
position when he only needed a draw and
uh he comes back in the armageddon
because of
a crazy wager by vishy anand seven
minutes in the armageddon
it's really unthinkable that uh
bid that low in amount of time and for
punk road he's doing the chess player
thing we all know it when you play a
game that you're just like what was i
thinking that supersedes all of your
greatness he just beat vichy on it right
you would think that there's gonna be
he's euphoric he's gonna go running on
the street celebrating taking himself
out to a nice dinner and meanwhile he's
like oh i'm such a bad player how could
i play like that but in reality he
played a fantastic match he dug deep
levi even from game one in that french
he sacrificed a piece for a couple pawns
it was better for vichy but not very
clear so pankratov is sort of the
person of the day but we can't forget
that there were four other matches and
some of them were quite lopsided yes a
lot of matches today were decided and in
just three games maxim bashala graf took
down eduardo to rezaga normally we have
all of the match-ups in a group at the
same time but sometimes for scheduling
issues we have to bump things around uh
noir back abductors took care of
business against boris gelfand quite
convincingly in a variety of different
ways one was he was a bit assisted with
internet connection but in uh in round
one he was extremely convincing with the
white pieces and roundok seduani might
have had the most convincing three games
of the day i mean it was from start to
finish it seemed like he was in control
of that match
let's take a look at the bracket in
group f
as we have every match-up finish there
this is
not what my bracket looked like uh i i
mean
i anticipated not your back would be
going up against vishwanathan
that is a massive win for him he picks
up a qualification to the round of
thirty two five thousand extra dollars
as well uh on the other height on
another side of the bracket you've got
ronix adwani whose opponents seem like
they're going to get their age cut in
half every single matchup if he keeps
winning so you got you know tapallov
geary and then you have potentially no
dearbek
that's a super exciting one i don't know
what's going to happen i did predict
that was going to be the match robert
what do you think are we allowed to make
predictions of course we've filled out
brackets so you know we already made our
predictions and those brackets are
public so i think on the top of that
bracket with a niche against raunch uh
the way rounded play was very impressive
but i think depaul of style played into
ronald's hands somewhat because uh
topolov he loves fascinating attacking
chess and roundup was was able to punish
him in game two when it was a positional
battle and then all of a sudden
lashed out with c5 that was a mistake
and great awareness by roundnuck but i
think anish how do you beat that guy we
were talking about joe and june trying
to beat him in game four in general the
guy is so solid and he plays a lot of
bullet chess so he's got great mouse
skills so i'm just thinking that anish
has to be the favorite but ramik has
good chances and the other side of
things nordie beck maybe he's the
happiest person that vishy lost with all
due respect to pablo pankratov i mean
the guy played an excellent series of
games against vichy but i think if
you're nerdy back you're kind of
expecting to play vichy and worried that
you're about to play this former world
champion all his preparation pancroative
was impressive but he um you know also
showed that he is very human especially
in game four there where that's maybe
inexcusable or unexplainable
inexplicable whatever word uh fills in
the blank there uh that was maybe the
most surprising part of this entire day
was that game four but when all is said
and done pancroats i mean he deserves a
world of credit to make it to the round
of 32 winning minimum 10k and beating
the legendary viciana
yeah just
incredible i i have to say it was
we keep sort of preemptively apologizing
to him a little bit because
we're all in shock it was an amazing day
for him now he has to take on the world
rapid champion if you have to make a top
five potentially to win this entire
thing no dear breck might be in your top
three okay so it's it's
going to be a very tough matchup for him
against no direct and the only thing i
really think that that is could
potentially could be a problem for
nojibrick is overconfidence that that's
really just it like he had a rough game
at the olympia versus hari krishna if
pancrate shows up with really solid
preparation i think he's going to be in
good shape i do agree with what uh what
you said about anish giri
and these are the three matchups that
will be in our coverage in about an hour
and a half right we do come back for cgc
a little bit later with two different
hosts we have group a
and then we have the entirety of group d
so group a is david navarro versus
mickey adams uh uh we have dmitry and
draken versus aramha kobian and we have
uh vladimir putih versus
perhaps the most interesting matchup is
fedese of komski but the most intriguing
one is the fact that hakabian doesn't
even have a photo it's like mortal
kombat you know he's just
faceless killer
well i was going to say after today
about the other match there navarra and
mickey adams the single like nicest
matchup you could possibly make in the
world of chess like these two people are
exceptionally kind and fantastic players
so they're not kind to their opponents
over the board but seriously i mean
really some of the best human beings on
the planet so that's a really exciting
matchup those players show so much
respect to their opposition it will be
fun one for sure and i just you know got
to say levy it's been an absolute blast
i
what we saw today was just great chess
some mistakes for sure
but ultimately i think pablo pankratov
he is the kind of hero of the moment i
mean all of india is mad at him but when
they get over it they'll realize that
this was a once in a lifetime
accomplishment of a player who's been
great his entire career may be lesser
known but the fact that he was able to
take down
one of the best players of all time in
not just a single game which happens of
course when you're a gm but in a series
of four games where he lost the fourth
and came back in armageddon i know we
were maybe sounding a bit harsh on
pancroat but he really just deserves
just a huge round of applause from
everybody because that's a
marvelous marvelous achievement yeah i
concur absolutely with i agree just
wholeheartedly with everything you said
we also were a bit nervous that going
into that armageddon he would be on tilt
and i think he was definitely boosted up
a bit by
what will go down as the the
questionable decision of the match like
right the talking point of the match of
vishyanan knowing he was getting a
matchup of seven minutes versus 15 it
was 100 confirmed with staff uh at least
from from from what we saw and for a
while it was going quite well he got
within about two or three minutes with a
stable position but pavel just went on
the attack and he deserves full credit
for a massive upset group f is now set
in stone uh and we will
end our morning coverage of the
chess.com global championship will
return in about 90 minutes uh with the
entirety and both matchups of group d as
well as a bonus matchup with group a
robert
uh if i have to wake up at 5 30 in the
morning there's nobody i would rather
talk about chess with all right so
uh i hope you uh you you feel the same
although you know i gotta say you and
there this guy are very good duo as well
so i'll uh i'll be i'll be walmart and
eridsky for you i was gonna say that i
hope lucy's not offended by you saying
that but i'll talk chess you know i said
dog chest you know maybe i wouldn't eat
breakfast or something but i'd be a
little too gross at five in the morning
but uh this was a lot of fun it was an
absolute blast levy thanks for joining
me and you know looking forward to more
coverage and thanks everybody who tuned
in no matter where you are in the world
this is the global championship so we
appreciate all of you from around this
globe and levy again i really gotta
thank you it's an absolute blast waking
up early is tough but when i gotta cover
it with you it makes it that much easier
i agree and i think we are gonna do the
same thing tomorrow if i'm not mistaken
uh but we do have more chess for you
coming up in 90 minutes this was the
morning coverage of day two of the
chess.com global championship round of
64 knockout you can go take a break go
have a snack and we'll see you back here
in about an hour and a half
[Music]
so
you